I still have passion for the Mafia and I
think I'm part of the good the bed and
certainly the ugly in my time the
heydays there was bodies all over the
place
when you make a mistake I'm gonna be the
last face you see it's not the guy who
pulls the trigger you gotta worry about
it's the guy who plans it for the
biggest differences between you and got
it I did so many things for this guy I
rigged the trials I threatened people I
[ __ ] bribed people and he turns on me
doesn't history repeat itself
what if Sammy takes me up what do you
want me to do I'm a gangster how dare
you call the shots on who shoots look at
the whole [ __ ] picture you don't
think these guys got balls you already
tell this kid to go back
I killed Don cake it's all great it's
all about money what do you know about
what happened with John F Kennedy this
is gonna sound [ __ ] crazy I think are
you following any of the Epstein stuff
there isn't even a word for this piece
of [ __ ] Teddy Atlas said you went up to
him to want to train with the boxing
Teddy Atlas is an [ __ ]
take away guns from all the good people
I will always have a gun if I die
tomorrow this was my choice my life you
still trust people it's in every book
every move that shocked the whole world
what I did no regrets
[Music]
so the last time Sammy the bull Gravano
did an exclusive interview was with
Diane Sawyer on primetime TV back on
April 16 1997 Sammy is known as the hit
man's hit man he was the underboss - the
leader of Gambino family John Gotti
Sammy thanks for making attempt to do
this interview it's my pleasure so Sam a
lot has changed since 1997 we now have
social media we now have smartphones we
now everybody having a camera a lot to
change in America we have a Donald Trump
as a president so America has changed
world's changed as Sammy the bull
Gravano changed to an extent I mean I
didn't change much like people would
think I'm more coming out into a
legitimate business you're going into
Hollywood into a certain things that I'm
doing my life now I've changed my life I
still have passion for the Mafia from
where it came from how it started I
would exist it it's part of my heritage
it's not just the gang to me I was in a
gang when I was young but this isn't a
gang this was part of my heritage
started in Sicily in the 12th century it
fled to the United States now when I
said it fled it didn't come in because
they like the United States they were
running away from Mose lenient fascism
it made them come to the United States
and they landed in the United States and
everything that they were taught in
Italy they brought them here so I have a
different feel for it that is some stuff
that's ugly that we did and I think I'm
part of the good the bed and certainly
the ugly but I did this because of my
belief in goes an Oscar I've changed my
ways and I've moved on with my life and
I'm going in a different direction
even sitting here talking to you that's
something that you're not supposed to do
mostly you're not supposed to talk about
it when you flip or cooperate whatever
you want to call it you're allowed to do
whatever you want because you already
broke the golden rule by cooperating so
but if you didn't flip then you're not
allowed to do this because giving up our
secrecy we're a secret society and a
brother
and if you give up the secrets there's
no different than taking the stand or
doing whatever you can't give up the
secrets of girls and often even some of
the things that John Gotti did running
as Boston people cheer about what he was
doing he did more damage that goes in
Austria were being out there and putting
it on Front Street then ten cooperating
witnesses put together you believe that
oh absolutely
why do you believe that most of the real
gangsters believe that and know that
I've got 22 years in prisons I bunked
into a lot of guys and I bunked into
people and I said listen you were in a
regular prison now you're in a witness
unit tell me the truth
what were they saying about me you were
with this guy in this guy in this guy
this guy Bobby he was young the boss in
Boston and he told me Sammy
you want all the truth I am more crying
and complaints about John than you the
position he put you in he betrayed you
when he betrayed you like that that was
the same as a rat man that was
government is trying to put us away
that's their job your job as John Gotti
is not to put me away and if that's the
role you're gonna take so you can get
out and I could take the weight
that's a rat mo what happened between me
and John so I did what I did and and now
I'm going into a whole different thing
that's all behind me I see what they do
now I think they're pretty smart now
they went away from violence they don't
do that as much anymore when I was in my
time in hay days in 70s and 80s those
bodies all over my every different
family but today they don't do that does
it work without violence and structure
though isn't a part of the leverage to
impose fear it could be but it doesn't
have to be fear could be in a whole
bunch of ways let's say you're a made
guy you're a friend of ours a friend of
ours is a big guy you're a friend of
ours so you're not gonna abide by the
rules but you're not to worry cuz I'm
not gonna kill you
but I could chase you I could get out to
all five families he's no longer a
friend of ours don't treat him like that
you're thrown out now that's a big hit
so you lose your power and nobody will
respect you know
but he will sandwich nobody will
recognize you sometimes in certain cases
it may even be better to be dead it's a
good punishment but the effect of not
killing when I was around every family
had a squad of FBI agents who worked on
them each family the squad consisted of
a 20 some-odd agents working on your
family from what I hear now they're down
to three they used all those extra
agents to terrorists and 13 drug gangs
stuff that warrants it so but I'm not
killing they don't have depression and
then the RICO law and the laws are
crippling so me you and another guy but
all trust each other we going to murder
now the way the law is set you get
convicted on the murder there's life
without parole every one of us have a
get out of jail card free of course we
killed Joe Blow I get pinched for drugs
later and I'm facing 20 or 25 years I'm
50 years old I don't want to do it it's
like Oh brew government me you and the
sort of guy we killed him they don't
trust each other no more because the
sentences are so big in most cases that
guy's flipped some guys don't want to go
to jail
some guys are screwed when they go to
jail you know I've heard so many stories
with guys black guys Hispanic guys who
stood up and got sentenced and we're
doing that time with the people though
they took his money while he was gone
and they screwed his wife they did this
they did that you're begging for this
guy to cooperate he didn't cooperate and
you do these things then so he flips or
you sold him out in some capacity and he
flips like I did when John John told me
to my face at the end of the time he
said Sammy the tapes horrible they make
you sound like a monster what are we
gonna do so I'm controlling all the
lawyers you're gonna take the weight the
lawyers are gonna bring it out in court
that you're a monster
you killed all these people took over
the union's took over businesses which I
never did
during the trial the lawyers will say
you hear John complaining on the tapes
poor John Gotti he lost control that is
monster
Sammy the ball Tim it's that John so I
will go free and you'll do the time I
said are you sure that's what you want
me to do that it was I I'm worried about
the feds trying to put me away I've been
paged all my life I've raised that I
never faced my friend my co-defendant
wanting to put me away that's what
they're doing John is that what you
really want to do it has to be done the
streets needs me the boss you're the
sacrificial lamb I said okay you're sure
that's the way it is I got in touch with
the FBI
I flipped and I was gone that's what I
did my first bid of 5 years then I was
out for a while five years and they went
back in on a 20-year sentence and that
sentence when I started that sense I did
17 years several months on that sadness
the first six and a half years I get in
the hole and I got sick in the home it
took my teeth away nails that pre age my
skin most of my hair was lost and they
were reports he's dying to cancer he's
dying of Hashimoto's disease here all
these different things were coming out
but I survived it and I'm back out and
I'm making my life again look who I am
I'm saying what you're talking it's
interesting but going back what I'd want
to do is pre even this I'm curious to
know about the Sammy growing up like you
grown up in a family in Brooklyn your
mom your dad two sisters I think you're
the youngest of three who was Sammy
growing up what was your personality
like even at 10 years old 12 years I'm
not even talking 16 in high school with
the incident of you and your principal
you know you punching them in the face
who will you at eight years old who will
you at ten years old I think I was just
like any other kid I was the lecture as
a very slow learner
with books not visual things or hearing
things
but with books stuff like that the
number three looked like an eight so I
was always wrong so as soon as the
teacher said what number is that now if
it look like an eight to me
I would say three you're right not
because I was right because I was wrong
so many times so an eight I knew it was
an eight it was three invites of course
then I hung out with kids and I grew her
kids I mean just like any other kid my
father was a painter then he got lead
poisoning and he couldn't paint there
was just to be leading in the paint my
mother was a seamstress so she was so
good at it
she worked in a factory in New York for
Jewish contractor she used to make the
dresses for the models that they were
going to show the thing and sell it so
the contractor told her Katie my name
was Kay and they called Katie why don't
you open up a small little Factory
you're great at this so she talked to my
father he couldn't paint no more so they
opened up a small little Factory
together they knew all the Italian
people and ladies from Italy was here
they don't know how to sell and they all
went in there and sewed and they had a
little dress factory and then we used to
go in and help from time to time and I
was at the youngest of three I was the
youngest of five my brother died and one
of my sisters died before I was even
born
and what was left was two sisters one
was nine years older to me one was five
years older than me did that feeling of
you not getting eight three you know I
see this dyslexic did that create an
array gin you're like I'm a little bit
different why am I being treated this
way or not at all no no there was plenty
of rage there was plenty absolutely
since I got left back in the fourth
grade okay I don't even know how old
you're supposed to be in the fourth
grade but I got left back in the fourth
grade so now when I go forward they
they're younger than me and the teacher
would say a certain word a big word
there's somebody to spell it I was in
the back of the class all the time and
another kid to spell another word they
would get to me and saying okay gravano
spell cat the whole class would giggle I
was so ashamed in rage I felt
after school I beat the [ __ ] out of em
about I was actually older and bigger
than them and I was a strong kid I beat
the [ __ ] out although there was no more
lesson when I hit the seventh grade I
got left back again and at that point I
said schools not for me just not for me
and I hardly went nice to play hooky all
the time and one day that's how a thing
started within the teacher I got caught
by truant officers who went around and
court kids playing ok and I was a little
drunk it brought me up to the principal
I was sitting in the principal's office
and he was talking the principal and he
was saying this is what they are the
upbringing isn't there he used the word
[ __ ] it's a slur eraser slow
against what are you people and I didn't
bother me too much but when he was
saying what kind of people these people
are this is a result these kind of kids
so I one point I got up and say this has
nothing to do with my mother and father
they're hard-working people
this has to do with me he said something
about my mother father again I cracked
in the shadow I broke his jaw and I was
thrown out of school months later
in front of the Board of Education I was
transferred to another school
McKinley Junior High School was in a
different neighborhood mostly Irish
polarized the Irish in the Italian
didn't get along at all I wasn't a
bad-looking kid I got along with the
girls but not the boys every day I was
in a fight in trouble
finally I get thrown out of that school
- I did find a teacher in that school
really tried to help me and missed him
indirectly I respected this guy he knew
I wasn't stupid he just knew I had a
learning problem matter of fact he would
even tell me if you get frustrated you
want to walk out of the class walk out
and I got to respect this guy a lot and
I actually wanted to make him look good
so I was trying to hang in but I flunked
that school and I was sent to 600 school
and then his old misfits I was in that
school I think it was the first week
there was a guy sitting in front of me
was dressed and looked like a robe and I
said something funny the class was
laughing and he tapped this book his
Bible on my head on my forehead you
shouldn't do this
you're acting you're the devil after
about the third or fourth time he hit me
on that and we was talking I hit and
knocked his ass out I was thrown out
again of six hundred school the Board of
Education called me I was under 16 they
said he's out suspended on a sixteen
birthday you can come and sign him out
we never want him back in regular school
and if you don't we're gonna put him in
reform school so the next step was it's
like kids jail so my mother father kept
me out when I was 16 they went there and
signed me out so I felt rage but what I
felt I felt and I saw the pain in their
face like they want their son to be
successful or do something and it broke
the heart they never hit me my mother
had me brooms and mops and whatever but
my father never had me family of love
they loved you they they love they
they're doing I was the only boys a
little boy my sisters were older they
would take me though they almost acted
like a mother 105 years older ones nine
years old they're much older than me
then I found the gang the rampers Street
gang just like any other gang I guess
tough kids we got together and fought
and stalled and did things to us it was
the right thing we were doing the right
thing we're even helping our families
who were broke
at this point you're what 17 years old
no I mean I'm in a gang I'm 14 or 14
unit again 14 15 you got it so typically
when somebody joins a gang there's
something missing in the house not a
father figure or something like that
right but you have a love your mom that
you your dad didn't it you typically
steer the way around will forgive mom
cause it's mom what could have been done
to prevent Sammy Gravano from becoming
underboss Sammy the bull Gravano could
the system or anything been done to
prevent it and squashed it right there
and Sammy goes a different direction
with his life okay I don't think so
first of all my neighborhood was
entrenched to see the movies Goodfellas
and almost it was entrenched with Street
mafia people now we weren't in the Mafia
at that age we're together where is the
campus [ __ ] them and everybody else we
don't want to have nothing to do with
them but it's entrenched after a while
there they're my idols well especially
at 17 and they're you look up to these
people if you didn't look up to them or
you went overboard in some way you got
killed in those days hmm there was
bodies all over the place back then so
whether you like the guy who didn't like
the guy you knew your place to get away
from them you know I'll give you an
example one time my father tells me in
the dress factory he's gonna ship
clothes tomorrow he wants me to come in
and help him clip some threads put
plastic over the dresses that they're
gonna ship tomorrow I'm in the back
doing that I see these two big guys come
in and they're cursing at my father
about the Union they Union guys and he's
non-union and that curse their abuse and
[ __ ] at my father doesn't even look like
it's phrasing it like nothing's
happening
they walk out and I said who are they
Sicilian people don't worry about it
that's what I mean they they said
they're gonna come back tomorrow and if
you don't straighten this out you don't
have money they're gonna beat you up
they're gonna do that said break your
legs he says don't worry about it
my googa ba de su Vida heel till I talk
to him they'll take care of this they
got big mouths don't worry about it
don't do nothing so I went back to the
gang that night and told my friends this
guy Jerry pepper was that head about the
leader of it again and I told him so I
said I'm gonna take a couple of guys we
go in with me in the factory when they
come back if they raise their hands
we're gonna break every bone in their
body so Jerry opens up it's Jackie it's
the same forget about Frank look he's
got a gun he says if they raise their
hands to their father killed him give us
a call we'll come and get rid of the
bodies and the gun and everything don't
worry about it now I never killed
anybody never even thought of killing
somebody
I was physical with my hands I took the
gun and I put it under my belt if they
raised their hands to my father
I'm gonna kill them so I go there the
next day they come in I'm ready
they turn around they tell my father why
didn't you tell us that so V do is
yogamaya why don't you tell us Jerry and
they're talking sweetly if you have any
problems with anybody give us a call
they giving them their card give us a
call but take care of you could stain on
you you don't worry about it do they
leave so I come out I said that what the
hell was that they talking about
survival now I knew the guy cuz he was
my father's good mother he was smaller
than my father and he was this big it's
then a good wind could knock him on his
ass what the hell it is big 6-2 6-3 guys
what are they worried about him I didn't
understand the money so my father says I
told you we honest people we work if we
have trouble we go to people like
servidio and they take care of these
problems don't be excited so I said well
that wouldn't happen I would have took
care of this how would you take care of
these people yeah but not my shirt and I
show them the gun my father it's the
first time I thought he was gonna hit me
he flipped out give me that gun we don't
do that I told you we legitimate people
that's the kind of people he was Sammy
are you alpha or is your dad alpha like
you know just because it's a dad doesn't
mean one is a bigger alpha than the
other one did you have more of an alpha
spirit than him much more than alpha
you're much more than him so let me ask
you how much of you becoming who you
became has to do with your environment
and how much of it has to do with your
DNA and your wiring and the way you're
born environment experiences teacher
eight three dyslexic bullying punching a
principal versus your DNA your wiring I
believe it's the neighborhood the
environment is is one thing I don't
think it's my DNA if there was help in
schools
I could have graduated I I got out of
the 8th grade that was my last day in
school I never even went to high school
I ran unions and businesses all over New
York they shocked the whole world what I
did it's in every book every move I've
met with lawyers and don't want lawyers
when I look at that I said my god what
are you what are you have the lexicon
you do not what you went to school you
pass some tests he's dumber than wood I
think I'm smarter than them so I don't
think I can't learn I sit down and have
done businesses all day long I just got
out of prison not even two years
September be two years well I'm sitting
down going forward in Hollywood I'm
working on a podcast a lot of content
about my life it's not an easy thing to
get to that point I'm working on a book
possible scripted show down the road and
I sit down with businessmen all the time
I sit down with guys producers and
heavyweights in Hollywood and they say a
couple of them told me Sammy you're
talking talk like a gangster you're
rough talk and you curse a little big
you talk rough but you're super [ __ ]
[ __ ] you coming up you just cut into
this industry and you're making moves
and talking with people like you've been
here a hundred years so I told when your
kids are born make sure that electric
and they will they'll be good too but I
could I have enough brains I related to
when I watch the news and I all the time
these kids who go around shooting people
lose answers a million questions just
like yours why how come we're gonna gun
control
what's guns got to do with it now I'm
putting my criminal hat on God do gun
control take away guns from all the good
people I will always have a gun every
criminal will always have a gun it
doesn't come from different states it
could come from different countries and
if you were probably when you were
younger you heard the thing as if gun
they can make a gun we made silences so
that's not going to help nobody what its
gonna do is a girl is home with her kids
some guy is stalking a what's a rape huh
but he's always questioning if I keep
that doorman to protect our kids in
herself she might have a gun and blow my
head off but take away all that
protection she's going to exploit it
what about how many times the people
with legitimate guns save so many people
or stop somebody who's completely out
my this is a problem of people growing
up the first problem at home we all know
our kids our own kids you know if the
kids a little weird or his little upset
and he's not thinking right you know it
but nobody will ever call the cops or
anybody when they're kids they feel like
they're giving their kids up it's a
normal reaction they he's gonna be great
you wait and see he'll he'll change he
gets worse so now he goes to school the
teachers say but there's so many laws
and rules if the teacher says I'm gonna
send Jimmy to psych the family will soon
he'll chill yo get fired so you're tying
the hands of teachers so this kid just
goes and goes and goes by the time he
goes out and shoots don't forbid 14
people there's always a line of people
saying yeah when you look back I knew
this kid would be the worst but nobody
ever said that or did nothing that's
environment that's not de LexA thats not
a slow learner because the school system
should never if I wouldn't have been
called Alexa go if they would have known
how to treat it
I don't know what I would have been I
might have been adopted I might have
been a lawyer I really don't know oh so
you do believe you could have gone a
different direction of somebody you got
to hold you early absolutely okay so
this is social ooh got it so you did say
there was environment but now you're
saying if somebody worked with you
tutored you developed you maybe you
would have gone a different direction
absolutely I'm saying the same thing now
about these kids who shoe people if you
were to grab those people years ago
right and said there's a problem with
this kid that's true to him let's send
them to special places let's take care
of him maybe that kid when he's 16 18 21
whatever the hell he is he won't be
shooting all these people
the kid is bent it's not the gun now if
you took all the guns away and one of
these kids run into a disco and he cuts
loose with a bomb stead of shooting 14
people 60 people are dead are you happy
he don't have forgotten what are you
gonna say then we shouldn't have bonds
of course we're shooting that box
but it's the kid way never going to the
problem and they always ask this stupid
question what could we do how could we
stop it you can't the guy is nuts
even gang street gangs the Mafia they
don't run around shooting innocent
people we shoot each other when we break
rules we don't run around shooting
innocent people people will tell you
live in tough neighborhoods Italian
neighborhoods four years ago the Mafia
was actually a safe place for them they
didn't allow a rapist or a child
molester I give an example I'm in front
of my place on a hangout and there's
this beautiful woman she had a baby now
she's back in shape she's drop-dead
gorgeous and she's walking she walks
right past where we stayed we're sitting
outside with beach chairs talking it's
not like the movies people hooting in
hell it may be on a construction crew
but we don't do that I told my people
you do that this is our people this is
our neighborhood don't do that why he's
doing something no I said we know we're
gonna do that so you say to yourself
she knows she's drop-dead gorgeous why
is she walking right past us on our side
mystery you know the answer she feel
safer absolutely she don't want to walk
on the other side because people will
not who now she's lovely raped or robbed
or something and when I say the other
side could be around the blood she's
comfortable here she knows she's not
gonna get hurt her husband allows her
you go on eat eat they go right past
that stay by because we wouldn't allow
nothing to happen to us there's a
different vibe I mean even though
they're you know like people say he's a
killer he was involved in 19 murders I
was involved in three Mafia Wars I was
involved in two different families you
could say whatever you want to say but
the reality is like what do we do to
stop this change the environment change
the kid who sick coming up change the
kid who's the Lex Luthor to help these
intervene then years ago today there was
when I was a kid growing up there was
mental institutions then they took them
away there's no
felicitations eyelid Trump saying we
better start building them again you bet
your sweet answers you should stop
building them again put people in there
not to do time but to rehabilitate them
to help them look what we have in cities
we have zones we're safer for people who
commit crimes there's so many stupid
laws that it's pathetic it's tying the
hands of everybody and it's
deteriorating the country so you're
forced Second Amendment oh absolutely
that would be an understatement and this
is coming from a former underboss who
for the criminal if they banned guns
they would have an edge and you're
saying to keep the guns is gonna keep
the citizens safer absolutely listen how
many shootings are there 10 20 30
there's 300 and some million people in
this country yeah the numbers just don't
jive and and they're how many guns are
out there they say towards a million
guns so you had 30 shootings I mean
that's nothing how many car accidents
did you have how many drunken drivers
killed people how many did we take cars
away we're try and control the person
who's drinking and driving we have to
control the people who are gonna have
guns
listen I'm for the Second Amendment but
I do think on the other hand looking at
it the other way I used to go hunt I
would shoot a rifle that was a
bolt-action
I missed the deer I bolted again boom
makes the death he got away they have
guns down a shooter 100 bullets would
have semi-automatic like a machine gun
so in 10 seconds he could unload 200
bullets do you need 200 bullets to kill
a deer no so they could limit some of
that power dose and I was in the
military so those are military guns a 30
caliber the thing you're not care for
your body off when you get hit what do
you need a 30 caliber for why do they
need a 30 count you need a gun to
protect your house 38 a handgun a
shotgun a gun that it with a boat that
only sheets one at a time is fine you
can protect your family she could
protect herself so I agree
with that there's too much power and
when you get a nut and you give him that
much power then you're waiting for
something major tap so you leave
sixteen seventeen years old and you go
into military you become a corporal in
the US Army I think you served two years
honorable discharge you go to Fort
Jackson South Carolina you're working as
a I think as a cook was your MOS then
you get out how did you get introduced
to Columbo and then how did you go from
there to Gambino I was introduced by as
soon as I got out of the Army at 21 I
wasn't cook
I was communications I worked in the
kitchen and had a problem in the kitchen
one time and it involved racism there
was a black guy serving and I was
serving next to him on the line and a
couple of hillbillies came by I know I
knew about racism but not like this
I saw it in South Carolina it was a
whole different level I never saw it
like this so when he went to him the
black guy right in front of me he's
calling him boy this boy that go get
that boy give me more boy and I'm
listening black guy was a pretty strong
looking guy he didn't seem to faze him
not didn't bother him not then the guy
came to me he started with me because
they look at I came from New York hey
boy fill my tray so I got this long
metal spoon I'm fooling the compartment
with the beans or whatever it was and
it's starting to drip over so I stopped
he looks at me and he says he throws
everything on the counter and he said
boy will not tell you what pathan me you
whoop it on me and he's got an empty
trade he puts it back out won't put on
me huh and I whack him with the spoon
mad and he was flying him back but I
wasn't all that smart because the next
two guys were his friends and his friend
hits me with a tray and they go flying
backwards a little bit and the black guy
from the Bronx we were friendly he jumps
over the thing and he starts throwing
punches I get back over the whole places
in Africa we're fighting like crazy so
we're sitting the MP scum was sitting on
the floor meaning the black guy and a
sergeant comes e78
like that huh he's in charge of the MPs
and he's a big black guy and he looks at
me and he said you liked helping black
people boy he thinks that I jumped in to
help em but it was the other way around
but I'm not a jerk I was going to take
advantage of it I said well that's what
you dope I'm from New York I don't
believe in his [ __ ] and he winks at
us I know I'm not in trouble and I never
on line again I'm in the back with him
peeling potatoes when we come on so
that's what I was but I in the Army I
was in communications so when I get out
I get out of 21 I'm right back in the
rapids
not even one day goes by I go to the
family and they go right to the Ramblas
two years I'm back and then at the age
of 23 a friend of mine Tommy spero says
his uncle shorty Spiro his name was
Tommy as well wants to see me and then
he's a heavyweight guy he's in the
Colombo family he's very well known a
heavyweight he was in the original Gallo
war so I meet with him and he says
listen I have a lot of good things about
you I know a lot of things about you
you're gonna get killed
he said you're too damn tough you don't
want to listen you can't run around
you're not hooked up you got to hook up
with people I would like you to be with
me I will never lie to you I will never
backstab whatever I asked you to do I
already did it was music to my ear he
says in my crew you're going to be part
of my family
I joined up I went with him I started
having trouble with Carmine Persico
not trouble like he was he was using me
to do things give this guy a beating do
this do that and I was doing all those
things now his brother Ralph Spiro
wanted to put his son in so he has an
argument was shorty why you keep
bringing Sammy to Julian and he said
listen bro I don't bring him there
Junior's asking fam
to come down when they tells me and I
bring him down so a lot of jealousy
I'll behind my back I didn't know that
was happening and at one point there was
a guy with us Ralphie Rhonda
he went on a stick-up with another crew
and he gets into a gun battle with three
or four detectives and he gets hit 11
times and dies
I mean ships at bay you know bill dark
dingy [ __ ] bar talking to the old
man Johnny Rizzo the main guy a couple
of other people Louie Milito Michael
mwah - alley boy and a few other people
worth talking and this beautiful looking
blonde comes in short skirt I heels big
blue in here and then those days they
used to tease it it's and she comes in
with a guy well bull guy and they should
have got the other end of the bar very
dark trying he could only see them be
seen them but you can't recognize who
they are
the old man Rizzo tells me he says
semantics this girl uh was trying to
make a play for you she's eyeballing I
think he's breaking my chops because we
always break each other's jobs or things
so I said come on John she sit with a
guy we're gonna talk we're gonna light
up in a fight come on stop
can we keep talking Louie Molino tells
me Sammy I don't think he's breaking the
shot she's looking at you every two
seconds stupid you don't see it I can't
hardly see it
Charlie you know she's she's looking
this way how do you know she's looking
at me she's looking at you
oh so the guy gets up and goes to the
bathroom and she gets up and starts
walking towards us
Rizzo hits me in the in the back I told
you go over and see what she wants so I
walk over and who is it I'm about as
close as I am to you
it's Ralphie wrong his wife he's dead we
can have a look at it tonight she didn't
have that hair like that she never
looked like that to me
and I said what are you doing guys
husband just died who's this guy she
said Sammy life goes on life goes on
he's not even [ __ ] cold yet you can't
wait a while he says I see the way you
used to look at me
maybe I could get rid of maybe me what
get the [ __ ] away I went into a rage but
uh she got terrified she left the guy
left like I came out with to him he said
what's the matter get hot and get out
while you can go so he did the next day
she went to Ralph and told Ralph so
Ralph takes this as a thing this is
great he's gonna undermine me he don't
know there's all them people did he's
gonna make up a story that I try to make
her she won't go with me and I'm abusing
her he calls my wife it tells my wife
jr. Carmine Persico
he's gonna kill your [ __ ] husband he
tried to make roughly wrong his wife
he's dead and he hangs up on my wife my
life really is not a typical gangsters
wife I come home she's hysterical crying
what did you do we're talking about what
I did what did i do what are you crying
about and she says you tried to make
Ralphie's wife what are you crazy
who told you that Ralph called me and
told me everything he said so I said
then listen to me baby it's not crying
this life is so technical make sure that
every word you tell me is exactly right
tell it to me again if there's anything
wrong with true she tells me the same
story she can't even stop crying I go
inside and go in the drawer I get a gun
I get my car and I go to Ralph and
shelves I go to the door and we were
like good photos we all live together so
and his wife comes to the door hey Sammy
what's up I said I had taken out the gun
I had it by night at the back by the ass
as soon as he kept her dogs in the kill
right in front of and then I was so hot
she says did something go wrong ruff
took off in hours two ago is ever prom
no there's no problem just tell him I
was here
so when I went to turn to walk she saw
the gun mmm and she told Shorty and
Ralph and he came to the house with a
gun to kill Ralph
so there's I'm gonna supposed to get a
tremendous beating then it set me up
the old man Rizzo comes to me again
found out about it and said don't go to
this meeting I said
how could I not go these are my people
John this is none of your business
you're in you what the Gambino's it's
none of your business that's what you're
gonna be told you can't do none for
night oh you got a do so what do you
want me to run away I didn't do that
so he stays with me we go to see shorty
shorty gets together and says listen
John this is none of your business
but John tells them listen it's none of
my business you're right but I want to
tell you what I saw
and he tells him exactly what happened
he said Louis Milito was in the car you
want him to come in he was there
I only boys with the Genovese people he
was there my cues what these people he
was there you want to talk to all of
them that's not what happened Shirley
looks at me and says I know this [ __ ]
kid that do that wouldn't do that and he
gives me a hug Atticus he says go home
and don't come out so I could let you
know now unbeknownst to me the head of
the Colombo's come I was in jail alley
boy particles seen yet what's the coins
here he was acting boss and this went to
Johnny Rizzo's captain was a guy named
tidal reloj right up to Carlo Gambino
and bosses made a decision on what to do
the next day I would get entitles caught
I knew his son but I never knew him I
knew he was a heavyweight guy he wasn't
he was a captain a heavyweight I get in
his car and we go down to Carroll Street
downtown Brooklyn they talk a little bit
alley boy Persico calls man inside he
said we know the whole thing I should
give you permission to kill Ralph what
he did he mentioned my brother's name if
you would have got killed your wife
would have thought my brother did it
Oh ordered it he deserves to get killed
for that but what he did to you he
deserves to get killed but I can't tell
you to kill him because he showed his
brother I can't do it
so we're gonna reach a conclusion here
on what's gonna happen we're definitely
not gonna kill you didn't do nothing and
you acting like a [ __ ] man were you
gonna shoot him when he got to the door
absolutely that's why I had to go down
I was definitely the shooter they
already knew I was a shooter all right
we can't keep you in this family no more
because if we keep this together it's
going to explode the Gambino's talk for
you we're gonna release you to the
Gambino family with no restrictions
we're always gonna be your friend you
got to give me one promise that you
won't hurt Rob's pillow so if that's
what the decision is okay I turned
around and get back in the car with
Tonto we're going back and he says from
here on in you with us you wit me
directly you embarrass me us do anything
without my permission
you'll die in this bed right away no
questions asked
we went out of Linfield Isis all right I
want you in my [ __ ] club everyday sit
with me
I'm gonna know every time you get a
pimple every time you get laid
no matter what the [ __ ] you do in life
I'm gonna know I'm gonna get to know you
better than you know yourself
my life starts in the Gambino family and
it's a whole nother story and I can't
get into too much I think I'm getting
into too much already
people from the book podcast are gonna
go apeshit on me I guess the part is
though so now you get in and at what
point do you get introduced to Gotti
where you and Gatti's relationship
starts developing I don't mean God he
God he does something he goes to jail
for a little while a couple of years
that guy they shot in a bar he didn't
even shoot him they that's what was in
the movie but that's not true
let me ask you just a question before
you go that I've heard two stories that
gaudí and jr. never killed anybody from
your experiences did you ever hear about
them killing anybody themselves not
putting the head and somebody else doing
the work them doing it themselves I
don't think so I don't remember if he
pulled the trigger if he didn't pull the
trigger but I'll tell you right now I
wouldn't Bank on him not being able to
shoot you you wouldn't Bank on him not
being able to shoot a [ __ ] hot mean
it like that I don't know about John Jr
but the father would kill you in a
minute I didn't pull the trigger all the
time I was basically the guy who headed
and playing the hit and I let me tell
you really quick how that happened Todd
oh really got to know me and he said
Sammy
why are you always the front guy in when
you go steal would you go by Ali boy
you go in you're the first guy stick him
up doing this do that why are you always
the first guy in so I said I don't know
that's just the way we do it and Ali boy
monkeys Michael mother he's got my back
he's a tough guy so he says listen I
know he's a tough guy
but Ali boys not that smart would you
agree with that yeah at least a little
he that means would sometimes okay so
you are smart he said you know what
happens you go in he's taking you back
something happens he has to rearrange
everything and make things happen so you
just get away and he ain't got the
brains don't you think it should be the
other way around he goes in first you
have his back if something happens you
can react like this he can't and if he
does react like that it's always gonna
be something crazy and I love violently
boy I'm not knocking him he's telling me
and I love him - it's my Gabbana
my he's Godfather my daughter no he's
reactionary he just reacts you don't
think when he reacts so I said I never
looked at it that way he said later on
in life when you go do a hit it's not
the guy who pulls the trigger you got to
worry about it's the guy who plans it
the guy who plans that that guy can't
get away number one and number two that
you all get away you're a planner go
home and look in the [ __ ] mirror stop
running in first think use your head and
I thought about it and he was right I
thought he was 100% right I'm more or
less did the planning of it but if you
think that I would hesitate I'm pulling
the trigger because I'm the planner and
not the actual shooter and it was said
anybody could shoot a gun
you're pulling the trigger interesting
so how many of the 19 did you pull the
trigger on I'm not even gonna get into
that because it doesn't matter and this
by now I'm gonna have problems with all
kinds of victims saying all kinds of
things so I'm not gonna get into them so
in your world calling it means a hit on
you meaning you that counts as one of
your 1919 doesn't mean that you any any
any role you take you know what I'm
asking you yes yes but any role you take
in that murder you're part of it
listen there's a couple of guys sitting
here okay okay and we're gonna hit this
guy this one guy and you're in I this
guy's in on it this guy here over here
he's gonna pull the trigger and shoot
him you're gonna do this you're gonna
drive a car a crash car I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do that and you're
sitting in this room right here you're
doing what you're supposed to be doing
the attentions got to be around you so
we could kill it now guy comes he gets
up from there and walks over to got a
glass of water or something but instead
of getting the class order he shoots him
in that he blows his brains out you're
sitting right here you don't think this
guy's got balls choices you know to me
no you take away anything from in these
part of the head law enforcement don't
give a [ __ ] what what you did your part
of that it that's life without parole
you're a head guy yeah but it's your
function what are you gonna be now today
you might be sitting in tomorrow this
guy might be sitting there and you're
doing that it don't man who's pulling
the trigger it's a matter of how does it
happen how does it work when you're not
just sloppy in the middle of the streets
and you're it where it's perfectly done
and you get away with it so or getting
away with it
19 times if you want to but out of the
19 it's not necessarily that you pull
the trigger no no no no no I don't I
don't even think it's important who
pulls the trigger you don't think so no
everybody in that room who's on this hit
is capable of pulling that trigger you I
don't want you to be the shooter maybe I
want this guy pulled a chain called the
shots on who shoots
how is that decision and how I planned
ahead but what how do you choose one
person over another person is
the case and how the relationship is an
example with a guy named 8db who got
killed sure that Oh quick the example
cuz I don't explain the whole thing but
he's going to come in to a meeting so
we're gonna sit at the table just like
me and you see actually a little close
so he's gonna get killed now what I do
is I told the old man Joe Perez with me
Joe get the vehicle he walks over there
opens up the cabinet takes a quick peek
thinks out the gun with the sounds comes
up behind you and it I get splattered do
you think I'm less than Joe I couldn't
do this you think this is a less
position or less a guy that bullet could
hit me too
I'm sitting it but what makes it work I
don't want to torture the guy I don't
want to wrestle with the guy I don't
even want you to suffer this is gonna
sound [ __ ] crazy I think but you're
gonna die you never even knew what the
[ __ ] hit you baby died and had no
reaction whatsoever it's like getting a
massive explosion in your body or your
heart stops immediately and you just
killed over that's what it is
so what I do it it's one that's clean
and I'm immediately gonna pick him up
and put him in a body bag
we're gonna get rid of him so there's
not stuff all over the place it's it's a
whole thing so I'm a professional okay
people would say on the street before
just before we got pinched practically
this [ __ ] similar Bulls got a
contract on you you're dead you can't
get away from this guy why because I had
blinders on like this the way I'm
looking at you now I don't look at
nothing I don't care about the people
who are in this room if there was people
I don't care about my family my friends
my uncle my hand money nothing just you
it's me in you and I'm gonna pick one
you're gonna die and it's cold and
calculated and not that cold in
calculate could you come in here with
your wife well you can't you're not
gonna get it that would be you
it will get him another time but I'm I'm
on you like glue when you making
mistakes I'm gonna be the last face you
see I'm all over you why did I get
picked 19 times by bosses Colombo people
actually first then Paul Castellano then
John Gotti why am I being picked why am
I in 3 Mafia Wars
why are you I'm [ __ ] good at it I'm
matado said I'm a thinker I'm a planner
I'm not a thug I'll give you another
thing one time Paul cast land on his
house is sitting there and he's talking
to us like he always did all the
heavyweights are at the table all of
them John Gotti Roy DeMeo me everybody
we're all sitting there and he says you
know in our life there's two kinds of
guys there's gangsters or thugs and
there's racketeers who more like
business guys it's very very rare will
you find someone who is both it's almost
impossible when you look around you're
either that thug or a racketeer he says
we have one in our family we should be
fortunate you could have heard a pin
drop everybody's had his time looking at
him and he said that guy and he was is
that Sammy the bull he's a thug and a
racketeer my [ __ ] chest came out four
inches my head must have blew up two or
three inches I couldn't believe that I'm
being pulled out like that and when
we're leaving I'm hitting guys on the
back you [ __ ] thug your honor your
thug I'm both and I'm breaking chops I
didn't even realize what what it was and
I thought this is how my brain works how
did I become a gangster and a racketeer
how is that possible it's impossible for
so many people how did I become that got
the lexer how the [ __ ] did I become both
stone-cold killer you could call me and
a [ __ ] great business guy who could
run unions I become both now it's my
upbringing what I learned from my father
from my mother from my family I absorbed
that and it never left me how legitimate
how honest
they were how they never lied over their
eye that never left me
mr. bend rakia I'm still mentioning his
name [ __ ] 50 years ago those things
never left me when I was in a gang
we didn't kill people like they do it we
just fought fights when I go into the
Colombo family beat up that guy Rob dad
take hijacked that killed this guy do
this do that and now I go into the
Gambino family I'm sitting with Otto and
I'm learning about business unions all
kinds of things and I always played
around what construction and I was in
businesses they didn't work or fuel them
had a fruit and vegetable store didn't
work but every time my business didn't
work
I don't even never thought I failed in
business I just looked at the business
and said what did I do wrong that other
people could have businesses and succeed
what did I do wrong to not succeed
so even when I failed I want I say no
why I felt and it would help me down the
road I knew that that's what made me
both all of those things that's the
highest level of compliment somebody
like him can give you to be I think in
front of 20 different guys or captains
and everything I mean I
that's his body's all right and I wasn't
the captain I was an acting cap now
how's your relationship at that time how
are you and God he doing together coming
up we're doing fine I don't really know
God I know of him I think I was made
1976 I think he was made in 77 so he was
made after me God he was made after you
yes
interesting yeah so they kept it open
for how long the baby oh it's open four
years is nothing really closed
got it so why did I why did he close in
the first place for 19 years or 18 years
who was born and I was from 1955 or
something like that who are 1957 to 1975
they closed it because some people were
charging money to get me well some
people were putting their sons in there
who didn't really belong I guess they
got so frustrated with it they closed it
and it didn't open them
so so you're in 76 he's in 77 and then
how does that relationship get started
Frankie to Chico I was very close with
all my all my life every time he would
he was a full-blown captain
I was made and I was in that title made
me his acting captain whom almost
immediately a year later I would always
patronize places that he would open left
our club a crap game it is gambling so I
would always go and patronize so I was
there and his father Frank ichigo's
father's name was Busey was a made guy
he was under title so was I now so I was
standing at the bar with Busey
Tyler Frankie the Chico's father and the
door open and John Gotti and a few guys
walked in his little entourage so he
says do you know this kid John Gotti I
said no I heard of him
matter of fact he helped the friend of
mine who was in jail and he did it in a
movie he had a problem with black people
and they were gonna hurt him he heard
that the kid was friendly with me he
intervened and straighten the whole
thing out so I was thumb buzzy he did
something like that I all right he says
yeah there's a lot of good things with
him he's gonna be like us eventually but
I know he's not a friend but he's gonna
be and when I say friend I mean the main
back what I'm talking to him then he
came over to BOSU balls hey Rosie how
you don't see how you Sammy Sammy yeah
yeah I met him and he says oh say hey a
lot of great things and told me about my
friend that he helped I said I heard
about that I appreciate it I said give
John the drink I said I hear a lot of
good things about you topo that's when
we met a little while later he went in
the back where there was a crap game
John was a degenerate gambler so he went
in the back and I stood at the bar with
Busey that's when I met him in 1977 I
didn't grow up with John and he come
from that neighborhood they have me that
we don't we have a long relationship we
don't I'm I'm on a whole other and I'm
Bensonhurst Brooklyn Bayridge
Bensonhurst you know I'm in that area
he's in Queens
almost towards Long Island it's not my
neighborhood but I did hear about it I
knew he was in the family
but I didn't know I knew he wasn't made
you know then he went to the can for a
while
was he overly ambitious on why he
eventually became the boss or was it
something where everybody around said no
this is this is the guy that's got to be
the boss eventually after you know
taking out Paul Castellano who read my
book coming out or do it listen to the
podcast it's too long her story
give me the shorter version of it I
don't you give me give me a glimpse of
it I change they say it again was John
Gotti was he overly ambitious where like
you know Frank Cullotta tells me when he
first met Tony Spilotro he knew
eventually palaca want her to be a boss
like he said since he was a kid it was
an inspiration to him was God he saw
ambitious where he wanted to be a boss
eventually it was a something where
people voted and said he has what it
takes to be a boss oh no no no he just
he wasn't even have what it takes to be
a boss we made him a boss but Paul
[ __ ] up he made a lot a lot of
mistakes I thought the world of him in
the beginning he lost my love through a
series of events and he lost the respect
that Frankie had for Paul had made a ton
of mistakes prior and there was rumbling
grumbling and growling by us the troops
whatever a lot of things he changed from
what he wasn't in the beginning he got
more greedy she had so much [ __ ]
money it was how could you be dad how
could you be greed it's got so much
[ __ ] money it's incredible he just
may want one band movie after the other
he was [ __ ] around with his maid and
this is not something we do you know we
go out as men we swirl around with a
bunch of dogs needles I got to test him
on popping out of our [ __ ] shirts but
me and Frankie are in his house talking
with him and he's talking about Gloria
has made was questioned by the FBI on
the street she's got a Colombian
accident he's so good-looking that agent
so Paul's upset about jerk-off overhead
turns around and I go like this I said
Paul do you want me to take care of his
problem he looks at me and he says what
and now I get a swift kick him to my leg
Frankie kicked me what the [ __ ]
Frankie kicked before what am I doing
wrong
then he says say that again and isn't
the veins in his neck and I dealt with
him I got his veins out of his neck a
few times but those veins are sticking
out of his neck and he said what the
[ __ ] did you say Paul maybe I think I
lost my mind right now I said I don't
know what I said I said if you need me
am I saying something wrong oh my god
if that goes away that's all we walk out
of the house Frankie gets on one digriz
because we know where the cameras are we
know he can't see it so that's where
hugging he's hugging me says you are so
[ __ ] nuts I said what the [ __ ] if
you're talking about what's about it he
said he loves this [ __ ] broad it'll
kill me and you fog the fifth Cadillac
in the garage is big [ __ ] garage is
glorious and Gloria dictates to his wife
now no Sammy did you see what we
actually got you didn't do nothing you
did a normal thing but she did you see
the reaction he was fuming when you did
that he's still in that toast wife now
he might have been fuming at me but I
lost a lot of respect for him because I
told Frankie it's kind of kazillion
dollars you can get the most beautiful
girl on the planet
buy her a [ __ ] house by her Cadillac
make all the payments go there every
once in a while do your little [ __ ]
thing go
what are you this she's [ __ ] two feet
well she's bigger than two feet but two
feet fat and ugly besides what the [ __ ]
and you disclose your wife and kids and
everybody like that in the house who
knew the story behind it with this well
they know obviously other people know I
didn't know it I'll give you an example
of Gaza Nostra that's crazy
tato who's my mentor who talks to me and
teaches me about Cosa Nostra the
different way than the Colombo's he says
one day I'm in the restaurant and it's a
neighborhood restaurant and he says I'm
sitting with my GU Mata
Agumon is his girlfriend you got your
wife and your Grenada
you know girlfriend your treatment
almost like a wife you see it in movies
all the time
he says and the door opens up and Carlo
Gambino a45 guys walk in they go to the
other side and they sit at a table back
then you don't even recognize that you
don't even send a drink you don't do
nothing you just look at them you may
have took your head like you just did
tilt your head a little bit org look eye
to eye
that's how saying a lot of each other we
don't this this is secret society and a
brother
forget Gotti this was back then it's a
secret society he may look back and give
you a little head shake he's
acknowledged you now there's a guy
sitting there there's five of them one
guy gets up and he walks over the title
a title how you doing
there's an empty chair right next call
he says go go sit in the chair over
there an empty chair for a minute
what's your girl's name Rosie hey Rosie
my name is my bababa Beth how you doing
he gets in into a [ __ ] conversation
to keep her occupied he goes over he
sits well call Carlo Gambino tells him
according to Todd oh how you doing Todd
oh oh good good Karl how will you do I'm
doing pretty good
that woman over there - good morning
yeah what's her name
Rosa she's a beautiful girl she really
is a beautiful girl they say you'll come
to this restaurant all the time I yeah
you come here with your wife wants to a
lot - yes what do you think these people
think when they see you now what you
wanna don't think night they never gonna
say none no no of course they're not
gonna say nothing they're afraid of you
they're not gonna say nothing I don't
mean to you or to me what do you think
they say to each other what do you think
they say when your wife comes in thought
I was bluffing it's so much prettier
than his wife look at the difference in
the bonney's how gorgeous that one is
you don't think they're gonna talk like
that they're human beings they are
saying if I agree with you when I look
at it that way it's pretty obvious
somebody asked you a question
taro do you love your wife of course of
course boy I don't love my wife let me
ask you something taro do you love me
of course of course I love you I hope
you don't love me like you love your
wife okay go sit with your go mom now
maybe a lot of people here this won't
even understand what the [ __ ] this is
this is causing Austria to the core this
is true Cosa Nostra how long do you
think I felt
Nolan Paul's doing this with the maid it
might be funny to people his maid in the
house in front of his wife and kids and
things well I'm out of course he's not
hugging or kissing uh leaving that thing
right in the house so when I look at it
when you get made and you're a made guy
we're brothers
your wife is my sister-in-law your kids
are my nieces and nephews I'm in the bye
see you your daughter go for bit and
she's acting a little stupid for a girl
come over here don't give her no more
drinks go home get the hell out of it
the guy looks you get out of here go
you're being you're not behaving nice
and before this one though we do that we
care about your wife and your kids he is
the father of the family so he's my
father
he made me she will take my sons you run
little children come over when I would
go with my kid put him on the thing
sit down give him milk and cookies she
literally it was like my grandmother she
was a lot older than me but she was my
mother
according to girls in Austria how the
[ __ ] could you do it's just funny when
you don't know but picture now your
father your father not pulll doing this
to your mother
how would you feel that's the way I'm
supposed to feel this is my father and
mother dad
what the [ __ ] are you doing bro I like
to [ __ ] just like you but in the house
like this well mommy looks like a
[ __ ] wig and other people know about
it too she looks like a fool to the
world that we do is that what you think
uh that's cause in Austria
people don't hear that people don't know
it people think when you watch all these
movies that we go out and we shoot
people and we [ __ ] drink and party
and that's what we
do we're not human that's all we do and
it seems like we always talk about the
worst you want to talk about the worst
of me the burden I don't know we want to
talk about the worst you don't want to
talk how I feel with that how I felt
maybe on some of those murders told me
the [ __ ] apart I went to a funeral that
I did I caused but I didn't cause it he
caused it
so when I went to the funeral of the box
and I didn't sign the Cross of course I
said it to myself look what the [ __ ] you
did you knew I would be shooting you
that's our life but you broke these
[ __ ] rules you knew you would die
whether it's me or Tommy or Lenny you
know this what happened it was me I
killed you but look what the [ __ ] you
did look over my shoulder look at your
family you did this you gave me this
[ __ ] scar of my heart you [ __ ] I
loved you like a brother
you forced this and if I don't do it I
die and you die anyway that's our rules
that's the life that's girls in Austria
so but people don't ever talk about that
or think about that I don't think I
didn't see this in movie so maybe if I
do it's quit the show it'll be in my
scripted show maybe if I talk on my
podcast on my book
things will happen and come out and I
don't even do this podcast book
interviews or what I'm not even doing
this for greed or money I'm 74 pushing
75 like a [ __ ] 22 years in prisons
all this [ __ ] baggage I give a [ __ ]
of course I want money not for anything
anymore
my life is damned they're over I want to
take care of my ex-wife my son my
daughter I'd like to help them before I
go and some people who stayed loyal to
me throughout this miserable experience
those are my motives those who clear my
motives you still trust people of course
look of course I trust you I already
thought you think I don't think I think
about every [ __ ] thing you think I
would sit in here with you and these
other people with the lights then if I
didn't think about you or trust you I
trust you
I think you're a gentleman I looked at
some of you pass things I listen to some
of the tapes you run I make decisions
before I move I'm not a Libra I'm Sammy
the bull
I'm the head guy still I think like
sometimes my wife oh she don't call me
that guy but she says Sammy well every
[ __ ] thing you do you think like a
[ __ ] gangster personal things that
come up I sense that we want me to be
you want me to be gay tomorrow what do
you want me to be I'm a gangster and
that's the way I think I was brought up
my whole [ __ ] life so I think of
every [ __ ] day I analyze everything
that said or done or anybody that do
business with and there's people who do
business with me now who has this
legitimate as it comes the guy from
mosaic that them and their wives and
people talk to me and though my whole
neighborhood talks to me loves me blow
horns they come over a woman rang my
[ __ ] Bell cuz I was home alone and
she came in with a pot of [ __ ] stew I
said what's that for she says and I said
I know you're all alone for days I just
wanted to eat eat she's given me full
tea and I get a little all over the
place with everybody just about I was
gonna say I'm not a drunk I don't drink
I don't take drugs I don't gamble John
got mad at her own game who blew more
gangsta don't gamble
I'm dis gangster what were the biggest
differences between you and God
personality-wise
every difference you could possibly have
I walked around with a [ __ ] sweatshirt
i abided by girls in Austria I didn't
want to be noticed and sore and go
around with a $3,000 Brioni suit and a
hand-painted tie and telling everybody
I'm Sammy Tabo one of the biggest
gangsters in the world that's what he
did
I'm John Gotti and we're biggest
gangsters in the world I'll never forget
we were in a club one night and one of
the John John had two bodyguards Bobby
Borriello wanted another guy and Bobby
Borriello whispers in my ears and Sammy
there's two people at the anti under the
bar
they're watching you guys real close do
you want me to go and rouse them up and
see what's going on I said no no no hold
up I said John
Bobby noticed there's two people out to
get into the bar on the other end all
the way at the end don't look now and
they're looking at us Bobby wants to
know should he go over there and you
know push it around a little bit
check it out Sammy no oh I saw that they
were looking that's our public that
state me hit me like a ton of bricks our
public now I didn't say this but my mind
said we're gangsters we are under the
radar we don't exist we're a secret
society and the Brotherhood what [ __ ]
public we're not actors we're not
married to actresses more public what
the [ __ ] are you talking about we don't
exist at a public he's proud of it he
called them over gave him an autograph
or thing I'm loving my head I said what
the [ __ ] this ain't even real
so what difference is I never did that I
was with him I was dressed we came from
somewhere but I never did that even
though I don't do it I don't brag about
see I spent 22 years in prisons a good
part of it is after I cooperated you're
going prison there for your cooperation
it's a tough place at the time I got
along with everybody
blacks white Hispanic Asian American
there even though there's not that many
Asians but different gangs abies from a
Mexican gangs and I think they killed I
didn't even get into that many battles
John winning all his races [ __ ] he
got hit he got beat to a pulp by a black
guy then he tried to pay the ABS to get
even I didn't have to pay nobody I
walked around I would tell I had an
argument with a guy on the phone in some
moose so when I first get into that unit
this big unit I said this is an MCC I
said what phone is ours that we use or
the fall over there on that wall and how
come he's on the phone no each tier as a
fool he's not on our tears he on out it
no but he takes the phone I mean he
takes the phone don't he have the phone
you
but he takes that one too takes whatever
Foley was takes it over 40 ones yeah so
how long do we have to wait for to make
a phone call
when he gets off no I'm not wait until
he gets off and I walk over and I tap
them on the shoulder bro you on my phone
I gotta make a phone call you want to
hang up
you said get the [ __ ] out is break your
[ __ ] face all right but get off the
phone anyway I want to make the call
then you could break my first you do
whatever you want hold on hey listen
I'll call you back got some [ __ ]
maniac not you thought you ain't gonna
use the phone oh I'm gonna use the phone
I'm gonna tell you what happens now I'm
squared up I'm ready to go I said I'll
tell you what I mean you're gonna fight
maybe you're gonna break my ass I more
than likely the way you look more than
likely you will don't ever go to sleep
you better kill me don't go to sleep
when you sleep out King I give you that
promising [ __ ] owns this [ __ ]
maniac
I Sammy the bull I could give it no no
you can't give me nothing you can give
me a beatin if you want right now you
can't even use this [ __ ] phone number
unless you ask my permission if no none
of us on my tier is using it I don't
give a [ __ ] you see I stood my ground
but I didn't play games like John racial
[ __ ] I didn't do that and I didn't even
say the guy was a black guy but he was
because it's not a racial with me I
don't give a [ __ ] what he was I want my
phone but I didn't play that game in
prison I they knew I stood my ground as
small as I am and as old as I start
again and I didn't [ __ ] with nobody I
didn't play any racial games I ain't
doing and people knew that more than
likely if we're gonna do sonmi we got
let's kill him because he's not gonna
just ignore it or walk away or accept to
be he's not gonna do that it's gonna
come back and that's what I did who my
life and in prisons the part earlier
when he were talking about you ain't got
er speaking and he told you you're gonna
take it I'm gonna get out because I'm
the boss they need me you do the time
and you walked away but what is the
process from there to Frank coming up to
you saying he's extremely paranoid in
prison he's you know out of control with
the
words what he's saying Sammy we gotta go
you know if we get out of this and we
leave we got to take them out
you're the boss that's please just let
that's before when's before your
conversation with them so the question I
have for you is the following that's at
the end I did 11 months with him when I
when that conversation happened I'm
already in prison 11 months with him in
MCC so all them things out stories like
that are pray leading up to this and I
still was there this conversation I got
22 years in prisons this is the worst 11
once I did in all my prisons and I did
rotten [ __ ] time and some hell holes
because you had a lockdown dude the 11
months he was in was the worst why is
that it was just it was torture he
didn't want to go in he did not want to
go in jail and he was [ __ ] weird I
give another story ten books I had
containers when we first get in a little
time has passed I get a visit my wife
grabs my hand and she's saying Sam you
are in so much trouble she's what my
aunt she she feel sorry for me I guess
so she's one of my hand you're in so
much trouble I read the papers I said
baby although [ __ ] the papers don't
worry about the papers they [ __ ] a
lot Franky LoCascio
we're on a visit into John Doe franking
the caps shield taps around his shoulder
I said what is it bro and I leaned over
so he could say something in my head and
I was gonna say he tells me tell your
wife to stop rubbing your head what'd
you say tell your wife to stop rubbing
your hand [ __ ] you talking about I don't
even actually realize she's won my ear
now now look at that she's wrong my man
and he points not with his finger but
with his head he nods to John so I look
up to John John disasters hands crossed
across his chest we're smart and they're
not I said what the [ __ ] is this
I turn around to my wife I said babe
stop over my hand why because if the
gods see it they might take it as a
contact visit and they stop the visit
because you're not supposed to have a
contact visit they may take that she
stopped
visit is over we go all three of us the
video was visitors a gun like I'm
standing at the back with all of us and
we're getting that dressed new strip
search I said John what the [ __ ] was
that all about what my wife said me
you're done the bush got act like an
underboss I gotta act like an underboss
my wife was rubbing my hand she wasn't
giving me a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are
you talking who the [ __ ] you think
you're talking to like that and maybe
you're right
and they basically bend over look up my
ass tonight we start getting dressed and
go back in but these things made me sick
there's a hundred of them when you're
saying to dine so your interview
I knew if Frank came he's gonna deny
that he never said he wants to be the
one that takes the hit he wants to one
be the one that pulls the trigger but
then you said you had 10 12 14 names
that you have to take out the brother
the son all these guys you ratted on a
piece of paper then you you know crumble
the paper you throw it away and you say
no then you went to the FBI
how were you processing that decision in
there no I went and what I went later in
other words once Frankie tells me that
I'm processing when we kill him again I
don't stop the process I don't just sit
on my hands okay though though we're
gonna kill him when we get out okay no
there's a process and I start thinking
we're we're gonna kill him who's gonna
drive him where we're gonna bury him who
do I have to kill his brother selling
this one that one Jeannie got it I'll
happen to like Jeannie guy I think he's
that he's the best of the Gottis at one
point it was 14 15 people on a piece of
paper I ripped it up and flush it down
the ball so I'm done I'm not killing I'm
not doing why I don't why I quit what do
you mean why I quit here's my best
[ __ ] friend my boss I did so many
things for this guy
all them trials him I rigged the trials
they threatened people I [ __ ] bribed
people and this is all fact and he turns
on me you love your wife she's extremely
loyal to you wouldn't every possible way
imaginable
suppose she turns on you like a [ __ ]
beast tomorrow well how would you feel
this is how I felt I was betrayed by
somebody who's a brother
father somebody that you gave your whole
life to betrays you that's some [ __ ]
guy who just pointed you out of a mug
book or a cap or no this is the the
closest person to you he survived that
kind of you you're surviving that kind
of him and now window when the rubber
meets the road he's throwing you to the
wolves
it broke my heart it broke me wouldn't
that be a bigger reason to make the move
though if you think about it what
happened with Paul Paul oh the heart
yeah I [ __ ] up I am a but tremendous
plotter the [ __ ] will found Frankie
tells me we're gonna go to a victory
party we were dead we're not gonna go to
the victory party we can't beat the case
normal Sam eatable would immediately of
plotted and killed him in prison and
I'll tell you another thing if he dying
in prison
their case I'm not even on the tapes so
get trolled shapes out or you got a
produce who's saying these things he's
saying about Sammy he's not saying about
Sammy the bull he's just saying Sammy
how do I know that's me there's a
million men saying he's out there down
in the [ __ ] case he actually talks
good I'm gonna make him the boss he's
got a run the family if I'm gone I love
the guy he's talking out of both sides
now but a jury will never know that
that's not me and there was a guy Sammy
cash who died not long before that I
could have turned around and said he's
talking about me he's not talking about
this and he loves his sin he's talking
about Sam occasion I would had a shot
but I wasn't looking at nothing I broke
the normal Sammy wouldn't have mentally
broke he would have thought just like I
thought about coming here to talk I
think about every [ __ ] thing all the
time
that whole thing to me was it's over
that's why I'm asking a question because
you're a methodical way of making
decisions if you would have gone the
same way you have that position you
would have gone a different direction
with your trends that's the only reason
I'm asking a question I'm not asking a
question to say it's the better decision
or not the better decision
if a person's always make a decision a
certain way all of a sudden there's a
change is that heart is that revenge is
that I'm done is that I'm not
this life shock shot everything I ever
believed did I give it up bro I'm done
[ __ ] the mob [ __ ] and I don't give a
[ __ ] if I get killed because that's the
rules I don't give a [ __ ] no more I'm
over it's done now normally I should
have just killed a Breton [ __ ] joint
[ __ ] the time add that on this time I'm
gonna get life on this one yeah and
another life I'm a jello - two lives I
don't give a [ __ ] no more I gave up when
you're gonna say these things understand
my daughter or my wife could at least
say well he was a gangster he stood up
and he did life that's him but I'm gonna
be abused by my own lawyers he's a
[ __ ] monster he's an animal that's
what my wife had daughter and son are
gonna have the rest of their life and he
didn't even fight back he didn't say a
[ __ ] shot there like a [ __ ] potted
plant and let all these things be said
so it must be true so I just I just
walked away you know it's interesting
you say that because you said once that
John doesn't want anybody to be as equal
right and I guess I was shining too much
and when you talk to a lot of people in
the world they'll say Sammy had more
relationship with the people in the
streets because John would give the
order to you and as the underboss you
would go execute it but you were the one
that was still in the streets doing
business - construction all this other
stuff so you had a lot of the context do
you think in the back of his mind when
he's by himself he's sitting there
saying the way I became a boss as we
took out Paul doesn't history repeat
itself
what if Sammy takes me out to become the
boss do you think any of that crossed
his mind
of course it did of course it did here's
a couple of things I'll tell you that I
know for sure there's a guy I think it
was in the Genovese family went to John
in the club meaning well he said Johnny
you really know how to pick them and
John tells him maybe he said Sammy it's
[ __ ] crazy he's controlling the whole
city of New York you can't get a [ __ ]
job unless you get a wink and a nod from
him unbelievable instead of
good that's my man that's my man you
want something done I'll get it done for
you know
it bought it the [ __ ] at him I had 200
carpenters working for me in these
partitions so my guys I go in we do a
good [ __ ] job I take away roll you
you and your [ __ ] I'm not breaking
your balls so these people ain't stupid
give that job to Sammi now I could only
take so much then okay then give it to a
Patrick Patrick you're gonna get this
job
good give me a little something over
here okay
John had [ __ ] money coming in up the
[ __ ] wazoo and he's complaining about
the guy disrespected him the [ __ ] you
talkin about bro oh yeah all right
saying I understand don't think I
understand it now leave it alone okay
that's construction so job didn't have a
clue so we go back to the guy you know
how to pick them
he got man we're back to that story and
another guy comes in from the Colombo
family Catholic a John I went to tallies
Sammy's club on 18th Avenue tallies yeah
he said went there on a Tuesday night
Sammy lends out money is a big shot I
had a million and a half on the street
so Tuesday everybody comes and divvies
up they make their payment they wanna
borrow 20 or 30 i'm hook get that
envelope for Patrick boom that's 20 or
30 you gettin I do my business on that
night my people are around tallies is
parked so the guy goes in he says wow
what there are [ __ ] Tuesday bro this
[ __ ] captain it was an underboss from
what a family's union bosses this [ __ ]
Chevy became so [ __ ] powerful is
crazy that was intimidating to him
rather than saying that's my man I'll
put it in your lap you're my man
somebody comes to me me Patrick set up
15 interviews and I make it a ton of
money with you that's my man you want an
interview go to Ed you want a podcast go
to mosaic I'm saying you know my people
why would I get intimidated by you but I
guess the power but I think it was more
ego John had an ego like the Empire
State Building like me if you ever see
me walking with him I'm holding the
umbrella while it's raining I'm one step
behind I always want to put him out
there that's your job bro that money my
job is being low-key and a lot of times
you won't see me in a suit and you had
no desire ever to be a boss no yet zero
aspiration I'm very happy being the
underboss believe me make me underboss
of your company macho happy I am but I
don't I don't want to be a schmuck and I
don't want to be you know I want to be
rewarded for what I do zero motivation
to be a boss zero I never really gave it
a tremendous thought underboss to me at
that time of the most powerful organized
crime family in the country was way more
than I ever thought though as I never
thought I'd reach that height
Gotti had five brothers in the mob I
didn't have no brothers uncles aunts
cousins nobody in the mark because you
know a lot of times great empires that
fall it's typically internal flattery
who gets credit who's getting the
tension who's outshining who how much
were you having other peers coming up to
you saying hey Sammy look man amongst us
we know who runs the family hey amongst
us we know who's was there anybody
playing that game in your ear or no
there was none of that flattery taking
place no the only guy who ever did that
to me was Nicky Scarfo he was the boss
of the Philadelphia family one day I got
home late around nine ten o'clock his
nephew Philly and that he calls me up
Sammy what are you doing nothing I just
got home well what's up he says my uncle
wants to see you could you come down
that let's go down to latex is a
two-hour 10-15 minute drive for me and
then I got to come back it's like four
and a half hours you disc and Sammy
wants the scene all right I'm on my way
well that's where you go he's just got
it I got to go somewhere and I get in
the car they go they take he wasn't
allowed in the casinos but he was in the
hotel pawn and he was up on whatever
floor I come in they take me to the
casino I go to the elevator I go up
there I go in the room he's in there
they Nick I don't know I did a lot of
things with Nicky
how you feeling bro says good send me
good not him a lot information I did
things for him I helped him win the war
his war so we're close and he always
comes into the family through me whether
it's in my house somebody else's house
my bone loss out somebody it's always
comes in through me so he says you
having any trouble with this [ __ ]
bomb who are you talking about what bomb
are we talking about John I said bro
he's my boss he's my [ __ ] friend why
do you want to talk to me like that why
would you say that with me why would you
do that
Sammy Sammy Mac calm down I understand I
understand what you know he wanted me to
come in through somebody else - Joe
butch I didn't like it
and I like the smell of it why would he
want to do it from day one I came
through you why would he want to change
that I don't have the [ __ ] clue I
don't have a clue maybe maybe figures
I'm tired I have no idea but please
don't throw don't put me on the street
that we're gonna talk I wouldn't do that
to you don't thumb through that woman
all right Sammy all right don't take it
personal but let me tell you one thing
bro come on we're close let me talk to
you what if you have a problem let me
know I'm on your side bro he's saying it
to you he said to me if you have a
problem keep your eyes open bro
if you have a problem come to me I'm on
your side Nikki I'm exhausted bro I I
thank you so [ __ ] much I gave him a
kiss I think you I went to frizzy I
think I hit him half on the [ __ ] lip
bully him a [ __ ] kiss I walked out as
I thank you so much Nikki I really
really do it's nice I'm just a little
cranky it's late I'm exhausted
you want me to have somebody Drive you
home nah get my car out I'll get home
don't worry about and then what no but
it made me think why is a boss of
another family out of state saying this
now Nikki's no fool
and Nikki wouldn't say that to me if he
doesn't feel something's right this was
towards the end and I've gotten other
clues with things but I still wouldn't
go against my better judgment than to be
loyal to John like a dog no matter what
happened
you ever get a dog and you could beat
him up sometimes you give him a kick at
his [ __ ] it is 3 seconds ladies wagging
his tail at you that's me I'm loyal to
anybody unless you [ __ ] with me or
betray me or do something crazy
then I'm do I could become your worst
nightmare I admit it I could become your
worst nightmare I want to eat you alive
he is these things and and he's catching
delusions and he's now trying to move
guys who coming through me had very
happily coming through me pushing them
in another direction why you mentioned a
lot of businesses that you did and when
you read about it you you got a lot of
things that comes up I mean it was some
construction plumbing the Lissa's along
this right drywall flooring you name it
how many of them were legit how many
them were not it was it a split between
whatever they were legit
okay they legit to the point that they
legitimate business but I have control
to push it in another direction but I
have the power to do that through unions
through jobs teenis true that
so I have that power and I'm bringing it
to people who were around me people talk
about how you ran businesses whether
it's the children of the deceased
fathers or whatever maybe based on what
they say you can agree or disagree with
this there's a system so a lot of times
there's investment companies where they
go in and their specialty is buying
businesses and they're not doing good
and they build them up and then they
keep and they take revenues was your
system the following system I'm curious
I know what you're gonna say to the
system number one step number one find a
local profitable business number two
given protection number three eliminate
the owner number four take over the
business
number five show up to the funeral would
you say that was a disease that's really
curious to hear I never killed the
partner or a business associate I never
went into a profitable company and said
give me a piece and I'm gonna give you a
baton never did anything that's in the
movies That's not me because after I
cooperate said how come nobody ever
[ __ ] ratted on you so it's the same
question you're asking me in a different
way I told them why would they
who don't listen to Gaudi on that tapes
who did I hurt what did I do
everybody I did business with was
extremely successful with it very few it
in my heart even contracts
I had verbal commitments I give you my
word you give me your word you keep your
books why why would I do it that way
god forbid you drop dead your kids take
it I got nothing to do with it
no I'm not gonna control your kids your
kids own it so we had no paper don't
even worry about [ __ ] like that unless
your kids have problems and want to come
to me then I'll talk to them
but I never bullied my way into anything
when I had the drywall company I had
over 200 carpenters working for a
contractor will call me up Sammy I am so
stuck I need 30 guys who no matter who
he calls he can't get 30 guys overnight
I would go in with Joey Madonna
he needs 30 guys we could shut down this
and we could pull something from the end
we could good 7:30 carpenters tomorrow
how am I [ __ ] hurting anybody I got
30 carpenters I'll give another little
example I was partners with a Jewish
contract a verbal it's gonna give me 10%
of the project sorry small high-rise not
a big big one the job is what they call
construction a bastard everything under
the Sun goes wrong with it no matter
what happens they order nuts and bolts
the [ __ ] nut don't fit in the hole
everything is a disaster every little
[ __ ] thing that could go wrong went
wrong so he calls me up Sammy I'm gonna
we're gonna take a beat in there really
I mean I know the jobs are bastard but
how depot are we and all my bundler
buddies would make guy best advisor in
the world for a snake snake of a human
being but what's the story I'm gonna go
in minions and all your renders maybe
250,000 now back then 250 thousands to
one for thousands a lot of money okay
let me we'll talk we'll see let's finish
up the job and see where it goes and how
it goes my blood loss was I hang up you
don't have to pay that why not he's Joe
what is he gonna do he is George and he
can't really do nothing it's no paper
there's no nothing you're right about
that
but what the [ __ ] is gonna ever do
business with me again
after I do this to this guy who's gonna
do business they had the business Sam
you control the universe barek I paid
the 250,000 I put up my head two or
three months I'm not exactly positive
but not a [ __ ] guy calls me up
another Jewish guy he says Sammy I'm
doing the project I heard he's got hurt
over there yeah yeah we took a beating
the [ __ ] job nothing one writing on
what I want what we did it just one it
went bad he says yeah I heard a number
would you lose well feel hard the number
tell me would you what do we had lost
two hundred fifty three hundred thousand
or two fifty is the right number I lost
two hundred fifty thousand he says that
is so [ __ ] honorable for a streaker I
never met a street guy like you I'm
gonna give you a piece of my job I want
you to protect me with unions and this
and then the other thing you know you
can come come in with the drywall in
this than their thing here's a guy in
these stories that I go raping [ __ ]
people left and right and they don't do
that that's why nobody ever rattled
around me except for John with his
[ __ ] big mouth nobody ratted on me
and I'm dealing with 15 different
companies
I got unions up the wazoo I don't back
up like when I told you how I shared the
[ __ ] money
everybody earned the union delegate the
the president the vice-president's union
delegate the shop steward how many
people did you have control about your
peak outside of Union I mean juror
judges cop I mean was it who else was it
not an M no judges are cops I mean I
there was cops a couple of cops working
that world but I didn't have cops and
judges
I didn't bribe people like doesn't want
to get involved with people like that
what's the story of the $60,000 to a
jury was that a complete that's true
that's true the 60 K to a juror yeah
okay John was on trial that's another
thing I did for John every trial he had
he threatened jurors or paid jurors or
bribed jurors I did everything under the
Sun the 60,000 was the head of the
Westies and a guy named Bosco comes to
me and says Sammy the head guy on the on
the jury panel for John's trial he's
facing life
I could get to him really all right
let's get there let me I want to talk to
let's cut that I work out an agreement
that I will give him $60,000 20,000 up
front 20,000 in the middle of the trial
and 20,000 at the end and after the
trial I'll get him a job as a teamster
foreman and they'll be making sixty-five
to seventy-five thousand the [ __ ]
vehicle seems unemployed I'll do all
those things and he'll become our friend
that's great I'll tell him but I'll know
a little bit more if hearing eggs in any
way shape or form and he could go to the
feds with this I'll kill him
once he thinks that 20 he's got to be
coming I'll be committed Sammy I'll tell
him myself I know him then Bosco's no
joke
he went to out of the country was
fighting him [ __ ] Bosnian Wars I mean
this guy was a [ __ ] maniac but we did
that so that's what we did in that
particular trial there's other trials he
had a trial where there was a guy in the
Carpenters Union and he busted up a
joint the guy who owned the place is a
made guy
John sent a few of the Westies down to
give him a beating
steady giving him a beating the Irish
kid is shot him in his ass guy didn't
die but it shot him not a guy was scared
to death they will with the Genovese
people we went to talk to them they
didn't want nothing to do with it do
what you want with the guy we don't give
a [ __ ]
now the guy was going to maybe be a
witness in the case of what happened so
I went to meet the guy a guy came by he
don't know you don't know who are you my
name is Sammy maybe you heard of me
Sammy the book oh you're saving a book
yep I'm gonna tell you something now
you're gonna go in and you're gonna say
this had nothing to do with John and I
give him a whole legal argument of what
to do you have two choices you can go to
the FBI and rat me out I'll do a couple
of years I'm not worried about it the
next guy who comes to kill you there's
no saving you no more or you couldn't
run just run the [ __ ] out of this thing
but you don't have to I'll always be
your friend if you do this in the truck
that's case number two - John wants to
sell me out after doing 11 months those
are two cases there's more how do you
process fear
it's I've heard a lot of different
things you say about fear I've heard you
talking to Diane Sawyer about what does
feel really mean you know you're
explaining from different standpoint but
did feel Drive you did you have any fear
how did you view feel fear to me is that
when I was young I mean I was doing a
robbery and I got shot and all kinds of
things and all my life I was in conflict
of different things by the time I got
out of the military even when I went is
in the military there's a fear of going
to Vietnam they were bringing on body
bags left and right so I'm surrounded
with violence and this and that in every
way you could look at it when I finally
hook up with the Mafia and I'm 23 when I
went home I said to myself you won't
live to 40 there's no [ __ ] way you're
gonna live to 40 you got maybe a 17-year
run so you'll either be dead before 40
or you will be doing life in prison
course you got you got no [ __ ] you
would do all this weird [ __ ] you had
accepted that I accepted that and that
eliminated fear when I'm 40 or 45 and
I'm doing things I have no [ __ ] faith
I'm in three Mafia Wars the first one in
the Colombo frame it was the second part
of the Gallo war
shorty tells me and I'm a pup nob
nothing sure he says go home and pack
your bags packed my bags yeah we're
gonna hit the mattresses back then you
didn't see movies like this what are you
talking about hit the mattresses he
started laughing he says we're gonna eat
sleep and [ __ ] together 24 hours a day
seven days a week we're gonna try and
kill the gallows and they're gonna try
and kill us you're part of us now okay I
got a couple loans a couple most I had
two three thousand five thousand down
the street nothing I said I just gotta
get the loans and I'll make some pickups
in between no don't ever talk to me
about money again
I got loans out there woody no talking
about money just what I said this ain't
about money [ __ ] the money your even
they don't have to pay me no we'll give
you money well feed you don't worry
about
worried about killing here's what
happens
Sammy we're gonna give you a little fact
of life they're gonna try and kill us
there's a lot of us there's a pack of us
we're a pack of wolves so one day you
want to go pick up your lone you sneak
away from the pack they see it
Sammy every week tries to go pick up
buddies you already get killed for sure
you want to get laid for your dick
you're gonna sneak away they'll put that
together you're gonna get killed you're
horny goat jerk-off and [ __ ] money
forget about family forget about
everything hit the mattresses coming
young kid I've been in gangs and I'm
tough and I'm this and I'm that this is
a whole new [ __ ] world there's no way
I'm gonna survive all this this is
[ __ ] crazy all together
I mean [ __ ] mafia war I'm [ __ ] 23
years old
this is nuts I'll never survive this so
it eliminated fear when we were going to
take out Paul frankly Chico when he was
alive and John and we were you know
everybody knows the story John with the
tapes and Paul got killed and John Gotti
became the boss but that's not the story
what happened before who was involved
how many what was the problems why are
we gonna kill Paul nobody asked that
question nobody asks the question of
you're sitting in the car at 5:30 at
night in Manhattan right before
Christmas there's tens of thousands of
people coming out of these buildings all
at once they're not going home now
hustling home they're waiting for their
families who meet them they go eat they
go see the lights they go shopping but
the crowds are astronomical nobody asks
what were you doing what were you
thinking in that car with John John was
my driver by the way I had the
walkie-talkie I had everything
so when we're talking about they let me
get back to him we're talking about the
hit John says we could do this and we
could do that and I said an idea and he
says no let me so frightening she goes
as ole Frankie Chico knows I was
involved in two wars already with the
Colombo's and then when Nicky Scarfo and
Philadelphia so he says no no listen Sam
he's done this let him pluck myself and
I plotted that hit I'm the guy in the
car with a walkie talkie with a gun I
made myself a backup shooting so there's
11 people on
we're gonna kill Castellano so there's
crash car backup shooters the four guys
who are gonna shoot everybody's in place
what's my position but backup shooter
I'm in the car and I'm calling the shots
while I'm sitting in the car
it's packed and I'm my eyes are all over
the place there's two [ __ ] cops on
the corner and that's only a couple
hundred feet away from I says oh my god
this comes down these cops are gonna
pull out their guns and make a move my
job now the guy who's not pulling the
trigger is to go there and kill them
so the shooters who can get away so when
you say well you're the shooter my job
now is to kill them and I'm sick I don't
want to kill these two cops but I know
what my job is thank God just before
they came they turned around and start
walking up the Avenue chatting the other
way so there were a dead there's
actually a cop from what I know in the
government knew who saw it and the FBI
asked them why the [ __ ] didn't you pull
out your gun he said this was so [ __ ]
professionally done I'm not a [ __ ]
fool there must have been backup
shooters over this guy was on two feet
of maybe 75 feet ahead of me if he would
have pulled out a gun he was right I
told the FBI he was right I would have
killed him I was told John pull up I was
jumped out the [ __ ] door and killed
him so he was right there this poor
bastard wherever he was that again going
back to who's the shooter that alley boy
go shoot him and you think from the
background where you're not afraid [ __ ]
no Teddy Atlas said you went up to him
to want to train with him boxing and he
talked to you about a fear and you said
I'm not afraid he says every boxers
afraid Teddy Atlas is an [ __ ]
Teddy Atlas was which somebody is
brought a cousin of some [ __ ] body he
was what he had to say these things I
think but he did ask me that question I
would box I would train with not him
with another guy but he knew and he was
like stumbled one I used to take care of
him and I wanted him to train my son my
son wanted to fight so I said Teddy
train him a little bit he can fight like
a bastard he just don't want to fight
he's more like my wife than they are
yeah you don't want to fight you what
you'd have to
go there and hit him for him to fight
he'll fight back and you wish you didn't
hit him he's a tough little bastard but
he won't fight he's calm nature if you
argue too much and you get stupid he'll
walk away from you he's not afraid he
just won't won't fight you know I don't
want to borrow much so he's the opposite
of me so Teddy Atlas said to me one day
are you afraid and said no I didn't say
I don't have fear I said no in other
words the reason I said no is when I go
in the ring and I did fighting a little
bit I'm not professional but in the ring
in the clubhouse and the whatever so I
see a guy on the other end of the ring
this [ __ ] got he's got ripples
he's so ripped
Ahava it's not fear if the bell rings
I'm gonna fight him but I already know I
might get a beating now if I was afraid
what do I do what am i doing in the ring
if I'm afraid but he took it to a
different level meaning that's cowardice
his cow would be saying he's not afraid
he's really afraid he's talking so it
was it was a whole creative thing which
there was a whole entourage of people
who wanted to make me look bad and say
things like he's an animal he did this
and that he's afraid so if he's
listening to this [ __ ] thing
he's just tremendous trainer I don't
know how old he is I'm 74 pushing 75
Teddy come down and put the [ __ ]
gloves on with me I'll show you how
scared I am of you and you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] cut that put the gloves on with me
or meet me in a bar or meet me in a back
alley
you [ __ ] Punk then he said and I was
putting on weight that I went through a
hypnotist he tells me about it it's just
all these fighters who go into what are
they going in for diets for this for
that so I hooked up with their hypnotist
he was on the program though and I he
says what do you want nothing I want to
keep up my stamina number one so I don't
lose you know stamina and I want to die
you know that keep me away from doing
certain things eating certain foods I'm
a [ __ ] sugar freak I love ice cream I
love so I sort of tells the [ __ ] guy
who's a who's a Agnetha's hypnotist and
they make a big deal
like what I was doing but you punk-ass
[ __ ] you haven't done a fraction of
anything I've done good bad or
indifferent
you're a punk-ass [ __ ] trainer you
look like a fighter but you ain't a
[ __ ] fighter who'd you fight I know
I'm gonna have a war with it now the
reason why I'm asking this question
Sammy is because so in your in your 20s
you know our brain is still not fully
put together so in our 20s we're a
little bit more aggressive we take a lot
more risk we're not afraid of anything
then we go into our 30s then we got a
kid you know
Gerard you know Carolyn oh my god I you
know I don't want to make anything 40s
then you go do time then you're six and
a half years in the hole you got all
this imagination taking over your brain
there is no am I gonna live am I gonna
die then you get out and you're set so
are there fears concerns things that
keep you up at night right now like your
imagination sometimes probably takes off
going back does it ever or do you have a
hold of it today I got a hold of it
today we know what I'm worried about
today well you could say I believe that
maybe I was you know III think it's the
best way to go clay the truth you shoot
good and you shoot in the head you're
instantly gone you don't feel no pain
you don't feel not so that's number one
I fear cancer stroke I can't treat these
things more than anything else you do
fear cancer a stroke well I would I
would rather not have that yeah I fear
that but at this age I understand if it
ain't here now yeah in this cute little
body it's gonna come
it's sooner or later it's gonna come we
alts there's an end
I see rich people who take care of
himself
highly take care of himself with doctors
and they'll die 68 70 76 80 I mean
that's life that it's gonna happen so am
I gonna be afraid of it I'm not afraid
of it I don't want it cause I'd rather
die quick then die of cancer because
I've seen people die my friends your
parole of died didn't kill me to watch
him die like that I wouldn't want to die
like that I've seen family members get
sick and French when I was in jail the
second time around I'm in MCC in the
hole
I'm in bed and in four or five guards
come to my so hey I mean get
and look and they all look silent oh my
god something happened what happened we
want to tell you some news tell me -
[ __ ] what happened Bob god forbid my son
my daughter my ex-wife
whoever John Gotti died this was in 2002
okay one God look he don't give a [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] wrong you don't even know
what the [ __ ] he took why would you tell
me I am I I don't give a [ __ ]
get a get the [ __ ] out of it why would
you say that well Sam he was your enemy
wasn't my enemy we were like [ __ ] we
were like brothers we will attach that
the [ __ ] hip I don't want to see
nobody die like a [ __ ] dog in prison
with cancer not happy about it you
should be happy
why what why should I be happy to watch
somebody die like that I would rather
shoot him and I know that's gonna sound
demented but that's my life not watching
him die like a dog he died like a dog
some guy in one of the prisons a black
guy he came to me with a picture he said
Sammy who's this guy
I got the picture I looked at it looked
at it I said I don't know come on Sam
take another look I don't know who is it
he says it's John Gotti I did not hit me
I never seen anything like it in my life
before he died they must have taken a
picture of him
he didn't look nothing like John Gotti
it was horrible and it made me think
what a [ __ ] rotten way he died it's
the same but it also makes me think it a
whole [ __ ] goddamn judicial system
and how many guys are gonna die like
that die in prison what life so every
place I went there who's got life who's
got 50 years
who's got 30 years how many guys are
gonna die like that nobody gives a [ __ ]
well they care about is open the borders
and let them in how about the people who
are in prisons in this thing will you go
into prison I like I'd love to go into
prison reform and and everything like
that I've been with so many different
black guys were friends in prison and
the prisons that the whole system the
judicial system is so rigged I will talk
to them and maybe some guys would ask me
a question
it was so [ __ ] rigged began his
outdrink this poor guy he's broke he's
coming out of a ghetto so you don't have
the [ __ ] lawyer they give him a
lawyer or he gets a cheap as [ __ ]
lawyer who's really not even a lawyers a
jerk-off a horrible lawyer I'll put it
that way and he gets an investigator
they hire a drunken ex-cop who's his
investigator this broken-down lawyer
this broken-down cop is going to fight
his battle against there's four five six
excellent attorneys working on your case
to bury you against that one guy who
don't even know what planet is on and
who's there investigated the FBI how can
he win and when you look at the system
they're even lying and rigging [ __ ]
things and I don't want to say the
younger agents I knew they weren't
illegitimate but look at some of them
now how they get things that they could
go after Trump they could do so many
[ __ ] weird things so how does this
guy stay in a [ __ ] chance this poor
bastard and I got an eighth grade
education is asking me for helping
myself I said bro it's the lawyer I mean
I don't know the details of the case and
I'm not a lawyer ask your lawyer
wait until the end before trial and ask
him if he could get a play that's the
best time you can get a plate because
when they get close to trial they don't
want to even go sometimes they'll give
you a good deal it's cool if they can do
that and I feel so guilty even telling
them that because I really can't tell
them you're [ __ ] dead you're dead and
if you go ahead with your case instead
of taking ten fifteen years on a plate
you're gonna get lose the case and get
35 years so I don't know what the top
and then people would ask me questions
because they knew I cooperated with the
government and they would come over and
ask me questions the best answer I used
to hear is that it's not perfect but
it's better than Ethiopia's law system
now I'm in president what do I give a
[ __ ] about Ethiopia's legal system I'm
not in Ethiopia I don't even know where
the [ __ ] that is but who cares about
that I'm in the United States I got on
my last case 20 [ __ ] years but the
government listens but the sentence by
the guidelines is supposed to be 12
under low
fifteen on the high I got twenty because
Sammy got a lenient sentence the first
time but I got a lenient sentence and I
did it
what's that got to do what this says but
that's what gave them an upward
departure they gave me 20 supposed to be
two and seventeen and a few I did
seventeen seven more than I'm supposed
to do they're like a lifetime supervised
release and $100,000 fine and I lent
them money even the kids who got pinched
and one that a couple of them flipped
says did Sammy ever buy the drugs no
this is their informant no did he sell
the drugs no did he go out with Jews
hang it out no there were kids that was
55 years old I wasn't gonna go to clubs
and hang out with that so what the [ __ ]
did I do
I lent them money when I took the plate
I told Lynn Stewart was my lawyer I'm
copping out two things Lynn on this
plate there's reasons there's another
whole story you know be in the book but
I didn't even do she said what's the
difference I said you wanna know
something me write the [ __ ] is the
difference whether they talking about
fifty thousand four hundred thousand
pills or a million clothes I guess you
don't make any difference let me ask you
this question so you're running the
government you're running the nation
hypothetically okay and you're thinking
from that standpoint you're sitting
there saying to the one conversation so
I'm talking to this guy hey get off the
phone
no right now you don't ever get off the
phone we don't ask my permission here's
how this is gonna go we're gonna fight
you bigger than me you're probably gonna
beat me but don't close your eyes
tonight because I'm gonna kill you and
I'm not worried about going to prison
for two years I'll do my time I'll come
out it's not a big deal you immediately
go to the worst-case scenario right and
the worst-case scenario is if you commit
a crime and the government's gonna have
some kind of a punishment for you and
the punishment is going to present the
prison doesn't scare you so you got a
life penalty which is death penalty hey
if you do this we'll kill you let's take
that part aside you got imprisonment
what punishment could there be for you
to not even think about committing that
crime because you don't want to face the
punishment is there any punishment that
would have prevented Sammy the bull from
committing the front crime
no so it's not the punishment that you
were seeing I wouldn't a guy if I were
to kill the guy
the phone I wouldn't got two years or I
got life life and I understood that but
what I'm asking you is is there any kind
of punishment to change to say for the
rest of your life you can't do X Y Z or
we're gonna do this word does it hurt to
hurt the criminal where the criminal
says that that pain I'm not willing to
put up with well why wouldn't I take the
that's good that's a good point
it's a good point I'll give you that
it's good point but take my point how
about these [ __ ] people just broke
[ __ ] laws against Trump and broke
every law in the [ __ ] book they're
not using the RICO law against them they
used it against us the Italians the
black the Hispanic why don't they use it
over here if Cole me his daddy FBI
somebody in the Justice Department and
somebody in this CIA and somebody in
this organization they're all looking up
and they all broke the law let's assume
that's happening and that's true why
don't they use the RICO law on them that
they can't win they may go Rico so the
[ __ ] RICO law is made for me and
blacks and Hispanics and people do you
could put in prison you want the people
to look at us while you break the law
where the crook worry about Sammy yeah I
robbed two hundred thousand why you guys
are robbing Millions
listen I understand the government
better than anybody you know why because
they're all different families to me the
Democratic parties the Gambino family
the Republican Party is the Genovese
family the [ __ ] moderates as Colombo
family the [ __ ] media is this family
Hollywood is this family they're all
different families everybody's got a
motive everything look at the whole
[ __ ] picture it's all greed it's all
about money the whole country so if you
look at it through my eyes everybody's
doing what I did everybody not everybody
there's legitimate people who are caught
in the mix of this I'm not talking about
them I'm talking about these congressmen
and governors and people they call it
all the time left and right what do they
get a kick in the ass a boot on the slap
on the wrist why is all these other
people that law
it's got to be so good and so bad I told
you in the beginning you want to stop a
lot of crimes give opportunities we've
robbed as a mom you guys are robbing you
robbing too much
we took a sliver of the pie so other
people could eat human beings could eat
you're taking everything a [ __ ]
middle-class person can't eat they can't
go to a movie sometimes they can't spend
nothing because they're booked they're
broke because of reasons your reasons if
you want to hit me with three thousand
years okay but let me sit next to
whoever James call me hey bro how many
years did you get 40 oh that's cool
I got 25 well I got 50 well I got a life
where is his seat
where is he in prison in what cell I
could tell you all the black and
Hispanic and every [ __ ] body else
like me they're in prison now I'm not
saying if you break the Lord there's no
consequence make an equal fair system
the whole country left to me I look at
the country I don't know you know what
planet I'm on I got out of prison I've
seen phones I don't know if data use the
[ __ ] so now I have a hard time with
the phone I look at computers I don't
know what planet I'm on you're almost
eliminated my existence when I got out
you got to talk to the television go to
Netflix if you don't do that nothing
happens before when I used to talk to a
little television they thought I was
crazy
now if you don't talk to the television
you're crazy so look at the system don't
look at me as an individual I got away
with X showed it everybody so did this
whole country built on it look at
universities they got people hating
conservatives now I was a liberal most
of my [ __ ] life sometimes I'm a
moderate sometimes I think the
Conservatives are right I'm on that side
sometimes I think the Liberals are right
I'm on that side I'll give you another
example I'm in the [ __ ] gym I go to
the gym and there's a whirlpool I'm
sitting in there for my [ __ ]
raggedy-ass bones and I'm getting a
whirlpool and there's a woman in there
and a guy he's sitting up on top put his
feet in the [ __ ] thing and she's in
the upturn deck and they're talking
about letting the illegal
aliens in we should give them licenses
and we should give them cause and we
should give them Social Security and we
should give them food stand we should
give them this and this and I'm
listening if they don't think Ted 1215
minutes goes by I'm toasted I'm ready to
get out I got open my mouth that's just
me
I said do people mind if I injected
myself into your conversation for two or
three minutes because I'm gonna get out
no no no god I said use a really really
good people both things really really
good people you're so interested in
helping people I like that these are
really good people the only thing is
that use a braces the both use oh wait a
minute wait a minute wait i right yes
you are
what do you mean we didn't say anything
about black people give a [ __ ] what you
said what you said if you want to give
all of this you didn't say one word
about helping black people in our
country their forefathers came here from
like [ __ ] slaves they're stuck in
some ghettos they need opportunities you
didn't see one word about helping them
just Hispanic people run it across the
border so you're good people but you
forgot a whole section of our country
and they belong here maybe not by their
own well but they belong here so I think
he's a racist and I'm gonna go because
I've been in this thing for 15 minutes
so I added my two minutes now I hope you
enjoyed it I'll see you later
I had get up to walk the [ __ ] out but
that's the truth look at what the [ __ ]
is going on in the country you can't ask
me how would you think oh this is too
much or this is this when all this is
going on if you want to point that out
all of my wrongs and I agree with you I
would say like I told you from the
beginning I wish I had a different
opportunity when I was born and raised I
wish I wasn't relaxing only god knows
what I would have done that my parents
would have been proud of me would help
me to go to schools I'm not a bad person
I don't enjoy this would've sound
hypocritical - I don't like killing I'll
enjoy it I don't like it I just do it
like a soldier would do it for the
military like I was gonna do in Vietnam
if I would've went there I don't know no
the only in Vietnamese people I know too
much
fingernails or my toenails and they're
great people I don't and when I look at
it sometimes I they're so nice I said
what the [ __ ] were we doing in Vietnam
nothing happened and they were there
that they didn't come over here and rape
our Vic the whole country from the
beginning it was a great country it's
there's no country like it I agree with
them the legal system there's nothing
like it but you gotta make it fair all
the way around then maybe you don't make
people like me maybe you don't have that
many people shooting each other in
Chicago maybe a lot of things are
different it's on you [ __ ]
not me the reason why I'm asking a
question I know you listen you're
intelligent guy no I'm actually sure
what I was going to do with this
interview I guess I really like you now
I'm not gonna give you no more
interviews but it's the last one you
honestly do I'm asking a question
because for me it goes back to how do we
prevent the eight-year-old Sammy from
getting into that that's the part and
then chill and then from there how do we
make the 22 year old Sammy who is about
to commit something to say I don't know
if I'm willing to face that crime he
never becomes the 22 year old ifs we
handle at eight years old yes we got
just the same ego goes by every [ __ ]
car in this country their God made them
that's our future we're all gonna get
old and die know what we do that's our
future all those little kids that's why
a child molestation and these
degenerates
you gotta killed that I believe in
capital punishment for them rapists ho
grand a woman she's just walking to work
she might have a nice body whatever the
[ __ ] don't you want about it you want to
talk to her and try to make a good but
leave her the [ __ ] alone if he hands off
our make the field when they young go
put back people who understand psyche
learning disabilities I mean they're on
it now for myseif from the kids my
grandchildren school I see they walk
more into it
get him even more into it start there
invest the money in the kids and you
won't have 22 year olds now you're
always going to have a nut that's why
gun control don't work
always gonna have screwballs and they're
always going to do something with if
they don't use a gun they'll use a knife
or they'll use a bomb to find a way to
get or they'll hit you with a car
they'll hit 15 people with a car just
complete [ __ ] semi when you went to a
prison you know a lot of people go to
prison they find Makaveli some find
Jesus who did you find in prison you
know I looked for Jesus I look for
prayer and Jesus wasn't in any of the
prisons I was in and I already knew
Makaveli so I didn't find him in prison
what I did find is this in 2004 they
took away smoking and I wanted to smoke
especially when you tell me I can't that
makes me want to smoke I go by the
Indians they have this little group of
aliens and they're in a circle they put
tobacco it's in the end to my game
regular tobacco shitty tobacco in a pipe
and they smoke in a pest of pepper so I
wanted to smoke so I went to ask them if
I could join their group and they said
you got to check with the counselor and
the chaplain and I went there my son and
my religion to India I'm gonna into
Native American Indian now you could do
that in the federal government you want
that yep I change it I'm in the I'm in
this circle now I went there to smoke I
went in with a lie they did the ceremony
and they never pray for themselves when
you have the pipe you pray for everybody
else but you i pray for Patrick that
this interview was great I pray that he
becomes greater than he is already and
if you have problems tougher bigger
problems why for something I don't
Patrick's wife is healthy and so I got
to understand the religion a little bit
and I got to respect it I did it for
five years one of the guys in there said
Sammy got talk to him in what he says
you ain't an Indian that's I know well
he said we have wicked I said what's
what the witches and though oh yeah why
don't you join us and pray with us a
little bit to the goddess and the God
it's alright I'll do that so I joined a
group I was Catholic growing up so what
I really really found out even a Muslim
guy came to me and want to be joined
become Muslim I couldn't do that I like
Paul I'm not gonna do it so I turned
and what I understood is this everybody
believes in God it won't form or another
all the religions is nothing more than a
road to God the Jewish community has it
the Christians have it the Catholics
have it
the Indians have it everybody has that
road to God
quicker people they all have to God it's
the road is different and we start
arguing fighting over it but we all have
the God that's what it is if you believe
in God it doesn't matter whether you
believe a monkey that's good
the guys I saw that found Jesus in
prison I've seen guys who found and
they're usually crying and whining and
asking for less time and want to get out
and do this that the other thing or it's
an excuse for something else the devil
made me do it I didn't do this on my own
I mean that would I would love you know
this is what they would say if they were
me the devil made me do it
I found Jesus in prison and I became my
holy role and that's it no I would be
lying through my teeth and one thing
God's gonna do with me I always said
this when I get up there if I get up
there he's gonna say one thing about you
sandy you're not a [ __ ] phony or a
liar you tell it like you feel it you
did what you did and whatever is gonna
be is going to be but to start lying and
crying how are they gonna face God
calling me as a lying about Jesus you
didn't believe Jesus you haven't had to
get out of prison but now you gotta face
God he's gonna know you you're full of
[ __ ] you go on the Express on that train
over there the [ __ ] out here so I don't
know now that makes sense I mean it's
it's your testimony but are you
following any of the Epstein stuff
because I know he was in the same
section as you and suicide watch what
his suicide watch did he kill himself
with no so what do you think I was in
ninth hour there's another one there's
ten shout okay ten South is extremely
secure I don't know if he was in that
but he had another cellie at one point
so I don't think he was intense out
thank South you can't even breathe that
when they give you your food think the
gods can't feed you they can't even open
the slide a lieutenants got to come up
and open the slot if he's up there I
don't know how to park there would they
kill them and there's only one bunk so I
don't know how he would even hang
himself so it's probably on nine sell it
don't take long
yourself I mean if he hung himself I
don't believe anybody killed him I think
he knew it was over and and he was going
to be tortured for his family whatever
and he took himself now I don't know
they're gonna keep it going see who else
now a lot of people like Clinton was
with him he said two three times five
times on the flights
he's wooden 26 times we also know he's a
[ __ ] degenerate so maybe those people
take a deep breath ah you know take a
personal Clinton wherever you are that
I'm calling you with degenerate but you
are what you are
I'm a man I understand but when you hit
a certain point you got to keep your
zipper closed you can't be [ __ ]
nailing a 21 year old she's old enough
to know better and I give you that but
still you're in a position decision
power but you're a douche I don't want
to talk about you boxing a gambling did
you guys ever do anything with Don King
any contacts with Don King yes I went in
front of a grand jury
I was I was subpoenaed in front of a
grand jury for boxing when I was there
when I was out when John Gotti Mike
Tyson was was the [ __ ]
now I had another guy and I can't think
of his name I knew the trainer and I
knew the black guy I was training in the
gym with him occasionally he was a tough
fighter and he was a little bit over the
hill so I thought of a thing to set up a
fight
I wanted him and someday I'll get the
name I can't remember right now but I'll
get him to fight the champ
in Italy the champion Italy was with two
brothers who were boat made guys in the
mob so I'm reaching them through the
Italian people
I want this guy to come in and fight my
guy - black guy and my guy who win so he
gets your belt so if he wins and he has
your belt I want to hook up a fight with
Mike Tyson and I want big money because
it's a champion he's got a boat you got
a boat the numbers are bigger we know
them I can probably beat you now if the
people around Mike want to make him duck
a fight I don't think he would do that
but then it's another story but we never
got that far the Italian guy had to come
here and fight a lesser of
first before he fought my guy and he
lost to that guy
so now the thing is off but in the
process of all of this John knows what's
going on I have a guy the street guy
can't even think of his name but he's
going to Don King talking about a
potential fight he's not having a lot of
luck Don King stands up he don't want no
part of this thing he mentions John
Gotti this that [ __ ] I'm a tough guy I
went to jail for dissing that man [ __ ]
John if I'm not doing anything that
[ __ ] so the kid comes back it tells
so I said John forget the whole thing
now it ain't gonna work
he won't do it Don King won't do what we
want
tell him to mention my name yeah I did
you don't want to be body he said he's a
tough guy he did time
really yeah tell the kid to go back make
another appointment ain't kill him
do you want me to kill Don King no not
you the kid this guy
you only tell this kid to go back and
kill Don cake yeah well hit him with a
proposal if he says no take a gun out
and shoot all right that's what you want
yeah all right if the kid it was in the
kid right
he's a guy who's tough listen you're the
goal you gonna hit him with this
proposal if he says no and gives you
that [ __ ] I'm a tough guy take the gun
out and shoot shooting my night go you
want me to kill Don I said it's not me
John wants you to kill what he wanted to
tell you you gotta kill him he took off
the kid took off I'd never seen hi to
him again he must have left the country
he took off so we never went after Don
King because I'm riding boy I'm
definitely not going after him cuz this
is insane now where we're hitting the
guy because you don't want to do a deal
meeting guys every other week so the hit
was given but the hit wasn't made it
wasn't great against a guy who ran off
the guy took off Sammy I've heard a lot
of stories with you know what happened
with John F Kennedy and the involvement
of mafia you know and I've heard so many
different stories what do you know about
what happened with John F Kennedy
I don't really know there's so many
people who
who were possible candidates for that
but to make it into a shorter story the
FBI when I had cooperated came to me and
one I was in Quantico and they said
there's guys gonna come down to you and
ask you some really high level questions
hurry they came down a bunch of guys in
suits and they said same things
what do you know about Canada is that it
yeah from what I understand you guys
should know you guys participated in
this hit it wasn't a mafia dude on that
Cressy help you people whoa scrub this
and they were left John Kennedy was good
he was with the mob he did everything he
was asked and then some his father was a
bootlegger there with us all the
Kennedys have dirty laundry Bobby
Kennedy couldn't stand the fact that the
Mafia I hope make him win the election
he went to war with them up he went to
war with Jimmy Hoffa he went to war with
the head of the FBI Hoover he went to
war with everybody he made so many
enemies from a guy that was loved John
Kennedy and the father was respect there
was a bootlegger and they were living up
to their word there are so many enemies
who knows rumor has it that there's a
whole concoction mixed with them all but
I don't know for sure I have no idea for
in a positive way just what I hear from
rumors and stuff like that last stinky
or speed round I'll give you a name tell
me the first thing that comes to your
mind
one word that comes to mind Philip
Leonetti good guy
combing schema Gotti Jr he didn't belong
joe Colucci good guy made bad decisions
Trump if one word is not even fair
because the only word I could actually
think of he has so many things on both
sides but he's the President of the
United States period like him dislike
him it's not your call Sonny Franzese
good stand-up guy Gotti senior a
tremendous disappointment
Albert Krieger a highly educated [ __ ]
Frank Kelly signs well that he was
really a good guy
Assistant Attorney General Linda lace
well as a reward for finding me guilty
and gone for this upward departure they
offered her a smorgasbord that's what
she needed and she probably ate
everything that [ __ ] richard kuklinski
is that the Iceman yes there isn't even
a word for this piece of [ __ ] I would
like to go to wherever he's buried dig
him up and shoot a - [ __ ] skull a sad
piece of [ __ ] Wyatt Hoffa
he wanted to Union back after he came
out he couldn't get it bad decision on
his part semi final thoughts here with
what you're working on right now with
the book and the podcast you said it's a
podcast this will be coming out
hopefully soon not too long from now
maybe a month a couple of months who
knows but it's gonna be me
talking to people or the ex gangsters
ages and myself talking about my life
from soup to nuts including this
conversation now so this isn't just you
this is you talking with other people as
guests as well on the show right very
interesting final thoughts Sammy you
haven't done this for quite some time
since April 16th
you know 20-some years ago the world's
watching right now this is gonna get a
lot of use this is gonna create a lot of
conversations what are your final
thoughts after every negative thing that
was said about me and all the lies I'm
amazed how many good people talk to me
deal with me trust me from different
businesses I know that they're a little
afraid when they first start but once
they get to know me like my neighbors
and people I'm doing business with all
over the place I have a tremendous warm
trusting relationship and it amazes me
after all the [ __ ] I went through
there's a world full of real good
[ __ ] people and I'm amazed by that
I'm enjoying that part of my
I love my ex-wife to death she's my
soulmate
she's not my wife anymore but she's my
soulmate my daughter my son my
grandchildren if you could find
something really Pleasant after all of
this [ __ ] which I did and I still do
every day and if I die tomorrow this
fulfilled me for all the pain and
suffering I went through and for
everything I did and went through this
made me whole again made me feel good
about myself and about everybody around
me and I noticed people whose call
themselves victims and say something all
you so-called victims you're you weren't
a victim when your father or your
brother or whoever was around and he was
running around with me and killing
people that don't body but bothers you
is that I was part of killing them I was
part of their life now there could be a
situation and I told my daughter and my
ex-wife and my son if I die tomorrow
this was my choice my life don't be mad
at anybody be mad at me I broke the
rules don't be mad at the person who
comes if they ever come period no
regrets very few very few I mean of
course like a human being everybody who
wants to play Monday quarterback is
there things that I would do differently
without a doubt I still respect the life
I think that people are left that are
around now that are in goes in Austral
the Mafia are doing the right thing
they're carving themselves and carbon
their appetite they're using their head
and they're acting like cosa nostra
should have act maybe in my era my era
was different and the errors before that
was like the Jesse James days it was a
different ballgame he was using your
head and you're a tremendous example of
quality goes enough stay away from for
more than that Bush
very little [ __ ] petty crimes
there's not 50 million agents on your
backs please just stop killing and doing
stupid [ __ ]
then you're gonna wear these people
around your neck you'll become the
target again and I can guarantee you
I've been with them for a while and then
I also met you know everybody I don't
like them I would have met a lot a lot
of agents that are really really good
people strong solid good people guys
retired still called me today he is
later
how you doing Sammy house this house
that house dad house I mean they don't
have to do that I know we went back and
forth talking about trying to make this
work you know thank you for making this
work and being willing to we pretty much
went through every question that we had
I mean there was no holding back on the
question so you were willing to be asked
any of the questions and if you're
watching this you want to find out more
about any of Sammy's podcasts or
projects coming up we're gonna put the
links below in the description Sammy
again thank you for making the time to
come out and be a guest on back
attainment appreciate you it's my
pleasure you've been a pleasure to I
hope you enjoyed this exclusive
interview with Sammy the bull Gravano
obviously there's a lot of technical
details in the making of this interview
a lot of back-and-forth but eventually
we were able to make this work but I
want to hear your thoughts actually want
to hear if your opinion changed about
them for the better for the worse are
you in the same place some of the
stories that stuck with you what stories
were made to SiC where you're thinking
about it right now
two hours after watching this interview
so either comment your thoughts below or
tweet me directly at Patrick mid David
that's my handle on Twitter I will
respond back and I will see most of the
comments on Twitter because those are
directed towards me and then on top of
that if you enjoy these interviews these
mob interviews we have many of them a
couple them I want you to watch it you
may be interested in one of them is with
the real-life Donnie Brasco you remember
the movie Donnie Brasco the real-life
Donnie Brasco is Joe Pistone we spent a
few hours together he doesn't do a lot
of live interviews and one of the parts
I asked him a question I said you know
was there every time you were about to
become a made man your undercover FBI
for six years did you ever get to the
point where you didn't want to come back
to your regular life and you have to see
the answer to see if you believe his
response to it or not and the other
interview is with Frank Cullotta Frank
Cullotta was the Hitman for
pilâtre in Las Vegas if you've seen a
movie Casino it's pretty much around his
life and what they did so this is
another interview to watch he moved
whit's pilâtre from Chicago to Las Vegas
and they ran pretty much all of Las
Vegas together another one to watch so
if you got any thoughts comment below or
tweet me directly and if you haven't
subscribed yet to the channel please do
so thanks for watching everybody take
care bye bye
[Music]